It's it's defensive calls for swatting now, guys. We've escalated.
The defensive conduct knows no bounds.
>> Like, I don't even need to go into that. So, obviously,
if I like if I say crazy unhinged about Dan, about Dan, his kids,
and his wife, it's fair game. You bring me to the surface, risk
me to dangerous, it's fair game. Okay, you did it first.
So, I'm actually not totally sure. Let's do the food shop stuff.
Okay. It's like packw watch on food shops. Very funny. Okay.
It's very very very funny. I think we should we should check
it out. No, I'm not going to do a poll. We'll just do this. All
right. So, if you guys missed Dan and Mr. Bootton decided to
do a little bit on food shops here. Let's check this out real
quick.
>> I got a chance to see some of this last night. All right.
They talk some [__] about food shops. They had food
shops, I think, hop on their stream and confront them. And then
she's basically just been like super annoying until Dan has finally
through trickery turned the entirety of the G DG sphere against
her and I believe she got banned. Did she get banned?
Okay, we'll have to see. I know I'm going to enjoy this. This
will be very fun for sure. But an opinion,
>> that's awesome. >> Yeah, you you can throw that
up there. >> I can throw that up. Steve, can you throw
this up on stream real quick?
>> Oh, yeah. Let me send it to Steve. >> Yeah, send
it over to Steve.
>> Leave voice. Someone you blocked has joined. If you
leave, you will still be blocked. Food shops is here. Children
should immediately should be immediately removed from the vicinity.
So, they're just calling food shops again for obvious reasons.
>> Yeah, that was that was me last night when I was in
Voice with Steve and someone joined at the same time and uh >> Oh
god, I just don't know what to say when they're in here. It's
like ah, you know, just I'm good, fam. I just I don't even want
to I don't even want to have my voice next to them, you know?
>> that's it. So, >> I watched this with Queenman
last night. This stuff. We were watching this in a VC. Okay.
Throwback VC. And the next part of this is pretty wild to me.
Okay. >> And by the way, okay, hold on. I want to throw
I want to throw something. >> This entire stream was crazy.
get multiple viewer calls about who will become the next person
to betray their dear leader.
Uh yeah, and they like try to paint me as somebody like again
I didn't betray Destiny, right? Destiny betrayed my trust. I
was the person who's like on his side. He betrayed my trust.
He is the per He is the betrayer in this, right? He is the person
whose actions led to people walking away from him. He is the
person who took action and caused everyone else to leave in
>> Here real quick, Steve, one second again. Um, >> look
at him. He's waiting. >> Okay. Yeah. Sorry. Last thing.
Okay. Um, I don't know Zip Zip super well. Okay. But I have no
issue with him. However, this is a strategy that the unnamed
one uh from the previous meme is continually trying to do because
they're desperately trying to latch on to someone else. Be like,
"Ah, Destiny is or sorry, Dan is against this person and this
person." >> I have no problem with it. >> Nope. No.
I don't think it's a little >> And they're very sneakily
trying to attach that uh to Next. It's going to be Radiant who,
you know, can redeem himself. You know, he's been a very good
sport. I'll say that. Oh, very good.
>> So far, even though I know >> they're like talking
about people who I think joined BC, like they're cattle. Like
they're cattle. I said I said to Queen, I was like, "Dude, if
Dan talked about me like I was [__] cattle, I' i'd
like I wouldn't be able to." Dan tried doing this with me a few
times and then eventually we like we like slowly broke him and
we're like, "Dan, you're crashing out. Dan, you're like totally
insan." Like we had to we had to break this out of him. Okay.
You can never just sit there and be like, "Okay, I'm going to
let him treat me like cattle like this. I think it came down
to a point where Dan was like, "You have to do this or else I'm
going to stream and take all your viewers." And I'm like, "You're
welcome to go ahead. Go ahead." >> Like, uh, you know,
there's some animosity and there's still some stuff to learn,
but still, he's been a good sport about it. He hasn't turned
and gone aggro. Okay, so that said, you're all in this by yourself.
You ain't got no friends. Okay, you you fight your own battles.
Stop trying to drag someone else down with you. Okay, that's
you. >> Sorry. Go ahead, Steve. >> I like Well, hold
on, Steve. I like Radiant. I think they're a lot of fun. They're
funny and they haven't caused, you know, any crazy issues. They
are >> They are. They are to be [__] The whole
the UB key thing was something for the ages. Like, but it's funny.
Uh, Zip Zip is fine. I just think he joins sometimes and talks
too much. But the same can be said for me, I guess. Well, the
same can be said for many, many, many, many people.
It is a skill that you learn to know when to shut the [__]
up, and I think I've honed the skill pretty pretty easily. Uh,
example, yesterday I just left when he was watching the Desh
debate because I knew that he needed to farm content a little
bit. So, I off food shops. I just >> I'm looking for I'm
looking for the clip cuz I >> I'll say I don't like them
because they come and channel and they they scream like a Okay,
she's got to stop doing that when I'm in there and thankfully
she has. She hasn't joined when I've been in there recently.
So, that's nice. >> Yeah, that's lucky for you. >> Hold
on.
Steve, hold on. >> I got to find this this Listen, someone
sent me like a >> I don't know why you keep saying she.
There you go. We're using her pronouns. You I No one here is
misgendering food shops. That's not happening. >> I I didn't
say he one time. >> We're not doing that. >> even
if we don't like them, we're still going to use their pronouns.
You >> We're uh sent an imager thing. I'm looking for it
meow. Um hold on. Stand by. Who would I have sent this to? It
would have been to someone. Hold on. >> I said M, not him.
M as in them. You
>> Dan needed some clips from me. I
He had a big he had a big folder as >> Oh god, >> you're
literally >> So then eventually they play those clips and
then food shops join. >> Um that that is a predominant
structural >> Zips have told me that you guys were talking
calling me a What's going on
>> Okay. You have clips out of there saying that you're
a
What are we supposed to think? I asked you in DG chat once. I
>> I asked you in DG chat. I said, "Are you a" and you
type dot dot dot and that was it. So why not just answer it?
Okay. Okay, why don't I just answer the question then? I don't
know who you >> Yeah, I don't know. Here's the thing. You
shouldn't lean into stuff that you're not okay with people calling
you. You know what I mean? And leaning into the thing for basically
anybody is stupid. I don't I don't even understand how you'd
feel bad for food shops, even if you didn't think she's a When
she goes, "Oh, well, I'm going to lean into it." Yeah, you you
just [__] yourself. Don't lean into it. I lean into
being racist. I can lean even into being anti-Semitic. And I
don't get mad at people who use the stuff around those things,
right? I don't go I go like it's not actually true and I don't
really think that but I understand I lean into the jokes so I
get why you might think that. I get it. Like I'm I'm not mad
about it. Right. You can't lean into being a
and then get mad when people get when people call you a It doesn't
work, >> You are. So I'm obviously trying to learn if you're
a or not. I've asked this a few times and you never answer. Are
you a Yes or no?
>> Okay. Trimplaz. I won't call you a anymore. How hard
is that? I I mean you can continue to call me if you want, >> dude.
Are we serious right now? What?
Her entire beef with with Dan was around him calling her. So
what what is the problem? What is the purpose of this entire
thing? >> Like I don't like what do you want?
Wait, what where is this even coming from? Who's talking? Is
it Mutton or is it Dan? You guys sound similar. >> Okay,
we don't sound similar. And also, I don't think you get to say
that when I've said it one time and then you immediately go to
a stream saying someone should swat my kids and harass my wife
and kids more. And I think to me that's one of those cuz >> Oh
man, I wonder I wonder where Dan could have got. >> No,
you don't get to come back cuz I I DM'd you. I was like, hey,
you know, like can we deescalate a little bit? And then you were
like, no. So that's where I went to. >> It wasn't until
afterwards. It wasn't until afterwards I asked to deescalate
and you refused to, right? >> About what? Well, they're
so that's kind
>> Uh no, Dan just sent it to them. >> Are you watching
something at the same
>> Well, I'm trying to >> So, so they were trying
to pull the clip up and then Mutton was trying to pull it up
on stream and then food shops left. She was like pedophile. They
just left her. They ditched. >> Oh, got it. >> And
that's why I was like criticize his parenting. Okay. That's why
I think it's a reasonable escalation. Okay. That's why I think
it's a reasonable escalation. Okay.
I hope that your wife gets harassed more at work. Okay. Holy
[__] effect. So like that again, we covered this
on stream so it's not that unfamiliar, but that is a reference
to the fact that I believe the Gat Fumodor person and Kiwi Farms
have both tried to post um information about Dan's wife and have
explicitly tried to harass her at her workplace, like giving
contact information for her workplace to harass her at her workplace.
I don't think that's like super hidden. So that is what that
is a reference to. I think that's a crazy thing to say. And if
that were the worst thing she said, I think that would already
be enough reason to ban her from your community. But that's not
It actually gets worse from here. So, shockingly, okay, it gets
worse than, "Hey, all those people who are like doxing and harassing
your wife, I actually think you deserve that." It gets worse
than that. >> Oh, is Dar still in here? He's He's been
in here. >> Oh, I don't see this as any different than
how Destiny acts. Yeah, but you have to remember that these people
see Destiny as like God. So, Destiny gets to do whatever he wants.
He's held to an entirely different standard than everybody else.
>> the [__] Chad. >> It gets a little
friskier. Don't worry, >> Can't even defend themselves.
If they would like to join Oh, okay. I see what you're saying.
If they would like to join, they can come talk. We're in the
GG one.
>> Probably got arrested again.
>> Probably in some drama again. >> I hear that's
been happening. >> Yeah, that's what I heard. >> So,
I think food shop stream now is just reacting to clips from Destiny.
So, it's just it's literally just watching whatever was happening
on Destiny stream. And Destiny stream is him playing video games
and chatting with
uh Dan, Darius, and Zipzip in a VC.
How this is compelling content to people is shocking to me. >> Just
remember, every single battle I pick is justified. Okay, just
want to just in case anyone wonders if I'm being unhinged. By
the way, this is the level of argumentations that Food Chops
has learned from 2025 Destiny. Um, I'm correct no matter what,
and you guys have to support me no matter what. That's essentially
what Destiny's arguments boil down to. That's what Food Chops
is saying right now. And guess what? She doesn't have the audience
of like 20,000 people concurrent to shave off 75% of by making
arguments like that. Okay? She doesn't have the numbers to go
ahead and say, "Ah, you just support me cuz you're supposed to
support me. That's it. Didn't have the audience to do that, man.
It gets worse,
>> They hate us. Here we go. They hate us.
>> Here's the worst part right here. >> Let's see.
>> Bro, you call me a ped. Yeah, of course I don't feel
better anymore. Yeah. For his wife. I hope they get harass more.
>> There you go. Go back a little. One X. This is like,
all right, [__] it. Let's
I've done more for less. >> Holy, bro. He called me a Yeah,
of course. I won't feel bad for him anymore. Yeah. Or for his
wife or for his kids. What the Of course not. I hope they get
harassed more. Yeah. I hope I hope he gets docked. I hope he
gets swatted. Yeah. I don't care anymore.
There we go. So, hope his kids get doxed. Hope I hope they harass
his wife and kids more. Hope they get doxed. Hope they get swatted.
Uh that's like an insane thing to say. That's a totally insane
thing to say when you've built your entire community up around
Destiny's community and you take the guy who you know for worse
obviously I was going to say for better or for worse but for
worse obviously Dan was a person who no matter what Destiny did
was always going to stand beside him right always.
And and you went and [__] with that guy like you're
not winning an internal power struggle against Dan. I'm sorry
it's never happening. All right. and she decided to say the only
thing you can't say to Dan, which is, "Hey, I I hope I I'm glad
your wife and kid get harassed, those people."
That's insane. Also, totally on par for the things Destiny says
and does, right? Destiny wants somebody who can play by these
exact rules, but this person's too understand that you don't
aim that exact level of vitriel. The Destiny wants you to aim
outwards at Dan. So, she just took like the standard of how DG
treats people and she aimed it at Dan. Well, that's not good.
You can't aim that cannon inwards.
All right, which is I don't know, man. It's incredible stuff,
isn't it? That she could take this like golden goose. She doesn't
have to give intelligent commentary. She doesn't have to say
anything relevant. She doesn't have to rebut anything. She doesn't
have to contend with any arguments. She doesn't have to do anything
except shut the up and let Destiny's videos play from his stream.
And she gets money.
But instead, she decided that she was going to give her opinion.
And the opinion she gives is, "Oh, I think it's cool to like
SWAT and Doc Stan's kids." That's the opinion she manages to
give. Okay. It's just sad, man. >> All right. >> Yeah,
that's about that was the main thing. Um, >> okay. So,
they were saying that they tried to deescalate and you ignored
them. Can you explain about that? >> No, that's not true.
They messaged me. >> Mood is making bank being the new
JTO. Well, I think the thing is is this is like directly tightly
integrated with Destiny's community. I had sort of pulled away
from Destiny's community was running a different thing with different
people. This is like specifically we're going to watch Destiny
VODs. It's all about Destiny. We're going to like rebuild this
stuff. And
maybe that I could understand it. I I do understand it. It's
the same thing as the Groper problem, right? It's the exact same
If you're in an economically anxious position, if you have no
economic future, you are feeling economic anxiety, your morals
don't exist. Right?
Mutin has no skill set. Mutin has no audience of his own. Mutin
has nothing and he doesn't want his wife and him to go hungry.
And so this was the most obvious and obtainable thing was to
go back to Desi's community and run a stream off of that. Whoa.
Is any of that false? Even less. Which part of that is false?
I if any of if you think any of that is false, I'm willing to
stand on any of those things.
>> Like no job and no college degree. I don't believe he
has a college degree. I this Oh, he used to have an audience,
but he was he was sort of he would stream in the mornings, right?
Oh, sorry. I meant no skills as in no training. Like no training.
Like I believe he went from high school to being Destiny's like
thing.
Destiny's like morning stream.
Uh I think he has rich parents. He and Peach own a house. Oh,
if that's not the case, if he's got rich parents,
if he's got rich parents and he made this decision,
I don't respect him at all. That's sad. That's incredibly sad.
Oh, I was I was totally ready to forgive this guy on the ospaces
of like people got to eat and I get that you make decisions you
got to when you got to eat. Oh, no.
That's
actually really rough, but we'll come back to it. Um they've
they've posted them. It was this uh first off, Mr. Mutton, how
many times have you called me a in the history of DG?
>> Okay. How many >> the hate farming is so tryh
hard? What do you mean the hate farming? I literally was explaining
why I hadn't gone after after Mr. Bootton. >> Times did
I say that I was going to go and swat and and harass your family?
>> Probably zero. >> Exactly. Um, I'm I'm not cool
with people around like that. Especially people who go and do
it to their stream afterwards. Seriously. And I'll never be and
that's it. So, um, when they said, "Can they deescalate?" I didn't
even I don't even think I knew that this clip existed. I will
never deescalate now. That is just it's just we're just buying
time until you eventually crash out and become JTOK 2.0. That's
it. So, >> there is no >> They even at their best
didn't have my viewership. didn't make anywhere near the money
I made and won't have anywhere near the already. They're still
like tied to before this they're still tied to DG. They don't
have viewers. Yeah, it's uh it's not going to work. Trust me,
it's not going to work out.
I do like that in everybody's head. I am the worst evil. I'm
like the worst evil to these people. It's unironically the whole
time. Hold on. It's just this. We're sitting over here. We're
sitting over here plotting,
moving pieces across the board. Okay,
it's I need I need my uh Hold on. I need the music. This is This
is the music that actually encompasses the stream right now.
Okay,
this is our anthem as we plot behind the scenes
on how we're going to get Pisco to next undermine one of Destiny's
positions. Okay.
>> Yes. Transfer. Hold on. Hold on. Yes. Transfer another
$1,000 to Dubbie. We need more donations.
Those were dollars well spent. Yes, they were. Yes, they were.
Buy
5,000 more viewbots for Nicholas J. Fuentes so he can continue
to mog Destiny on viewership.
Make sure we message Hassan.
Message Hassan and let him know to continue ignoring Destiny,
not to give him any
Yes. Yes. Good, good,
good.
We are
Everything is proceeding according to the plan.
Yes. Yes.
>> I don't know if any of that's accurate to the anime.
I just did my best. Okay, >> I don't really give a [__]
>> Let's keep going.
>> I'm pretty sure if I remember the deescalation things,
you just told them that you were going to ignore them and that
was it. >> And they said, "No, I'm going to keep uh
>> I don't remember. If I were you, I would show the I
would just show the messages right now just so we can move on
with this drama because they're going to try and make it seem
like you completely just like
>> here are the DMs. Oh, cool. Let's see >> There
you go. >> These DMs don't make any difference, by the
way. I don't know how you could possibly think if you have like
any capacity for critical thinking that these DMs make a difference.
>> There's jokes and they're serious, by the way. But the
problem is is like I've seriously asked food shops if they're
a before and they had typed dot dot. That was it. So when I'm
being told that she's a
multiple times and I'm being clips of her saying that she's a
what do you want me to do? >> I mean there's there's way
worse [__] that I've seen. I don't have it on hand.
One where they're like when I see a kid on on the walking on
the street I have to go the other side because I get nervous
and I'm like what the like this is this is these are not jokes.
These are like this is what the is going on here. So I don't
know what to say. >> Hold on. Should we should we play
that clip really quickly? I don't know if other people have that
clip. Give me a second. I'm getting lots of messages. I
also added a new emote real quick. We'll see you guys. How do
you guys like this? Oh, hold on. Didn't go through. One second.
Need to refresh. Kick. New emote. New emote. New emote.
Since I got banned from the GG community reposting them on my
own account, here is my What the >> Go back real quick
and I'll just grab the I'll grab the clip here that I sent to
Dan. One second. Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on. Uh, Dan, Dan,
Dan, Dan, there it is. Okay, I'll play this. I'll play the clip
of them with the street >> specialist. Like, for example,
I wouldn't even walk on the same side of the street as a kid.
Um, like in real life, um, just had PC. I was,
>> bro, this is just so insane. I was just like incredibly
definitely scared of kids um in general because I would be so
scared that I was like that I would convince myself that I was
a monster that uh that even being like even breathing like the
same air as children would be like >> viol like be a violation
right um so >> the things you say when you're definitely
not a when you're 100% not a things you say okay now I think
they go on to fully litigate later on in one of their streams
like their entire PCOD uh PCD diagnosis and so we'll save litigating
that for later. >> Yeah. I wouldn't even be like within
10 ft of them. So So the the exposure would be like walking on
the same side of the street as them would be like um even like
like like I think one time I high-fived a kid like a random kid
and that's it. Um like nothing. Thank God because they were able
to off to in copious amounts, they were finally able to high-five
a child.
Do not ask what got on that child's hand, but thank
I need to stop. I need to stop. Keep >> Um,
I don't know what to say.
>> Since I got banned from the GG community, reposting
them on my own account, here is my IVP ceasefire.
Hey, listen. I'm not okay with you calling me a stream. We're
going to have our massive disagreements and we're going to beef.
That's fine. This is a Dan, by the way. However, using Steve's
platform to call me a is another step up from trolling you. I'm
not okay with it. I'm sending you this because a friend said
I should try direct communication and I agree. Blah blah blah.
Um, this is all this is a fine message in my opinion. What does
Dan say? Never mention my name again and I won't talk about you
again. Go on random rants about me and find out.
Okay. I mean, I'd say that's fineish. Dan's a bit aggressive
here. Dan is aggressive here. I'll be honest. Dan, I criticize
you for your ego and you think calling me as a pet is okay, then
fine. No truth.
I think I
>> By the way, like how stupid is this? Again, I don't
really want to defend Dan, but he's basically like, "Hey, we
just don't talk about each other and >> make people go
on random rants about
>> Oh, I see. Wait, no, no, no. I know.
>> Basically, like food shop's job is to react to Destiny's
like personal VCs playing video games with people. And so she
probably felt like she couldn't react to those if she couldn't
talk about Dan. >> Compromising me. Consider how my entire
streaming career talking about Destiny related figures and drama
and my honest opinion on them. I am sorry. It is what it is.
I guess truth is impossible. Have a good day. >> That's
it.
>> I feel nothing. >> I I don't I don't give it all.
>> Yep. Shrimp >> to be used. You can unpause. that
we consider to be improper and that I think
>> okay so at some point here
foods food shops actually gets popped and banned got my perms
removed now hopefully nobody bothered me to join in to challenge
Dan as in she is now removed I guess from the DG discord I don't
know if this is up to the minute true okay this was yesterday
she got her perms removed I possibly got banned from the discord
not totally sure all right and Destiny asks why would you come
in in the middle of this thing and scream.
Stephen, it's funny you're into that kind of humor. So, apparently
she went on and just like screamed
and people didn't like it.
Got her perms removed somehow.
Obviously, if Destiny wanted her around, she could just be given
these perms back. But Destiny wants to drop her, right? She served
her purpose as a tool there. Destiny wants to drop her. Doesn't
really enjoy interacting with her. Doesn't really enjoy having
her around. Obviously, she does have real concerns of in the
past like attraction and so, you know, not a good optics thing
to have around. Served a purpose.
Time to be dropped.
Now, food chops didn't like almost any of this. Okay.
And she went on to react to, I believe, the stream we just watched.
>> Okay. So, she's watching the stream we just watched.
Her having perms was basically the only reason she was unbanned
from the Discord. Yeah, that's true. That the mods of the DGG
chord. Okay. And the Destiny Discord is fairly disjointed from
his community, but the mods of that Discord didn't want her around.
They had banned her previously because she's an attention-seeking
I don't know what else to say. I was going to say other things,
but yeah, attention-seeking.
So, they didn't want her around. They didn't want her talking
about anything adjacent to Lolli. Find her overall disgusting.
They had her banned before. She was unbanned so she could come
back and have perms and be on stream. Why did she stream when
she could have talked to Dan? I honestly, she could have kept
talking about Dan. It wouldn't have been a problem. All she had
to do was not do the whole thing about doxing and swatting his
kids and she probably would have been fine.
I feel bad for her in a way because Destiny made it clear that
like this kind of behavior was what he wanted from her and then
she did it and then she got banned for it. Did not realizing
that Destiny obviously would have implied don't point it at my
friends, point it at my enemies, right? Point that that level
of rhetoric and vitrial and hatred and and you know calls to
action towards my enemies. Don't point it towards my >> Okay,
so >> this is her reaction. I need to grab just a drink
really quickly. I will be right back. Give me 2 seconds. Okay,
I might be I might be like a minute and a half, 2 minutes. I'll
pause if I have to to come back and react. But >> it's
meant time. Okay, I want to very like I want to very much clarify.
Okay, if you don't believe me, then like it is what it is. All
right, if you don't believe me, I can't do anything about it.
Okay, back in the day um when I was like um an early content
creator, uh I made a lot of edgy [__] content.
And um I specifically honed in on like the concept of and stuff
like that. Right now I'm also made a lot of jokes while trying
to cover the topic at the same time and that basically caused
lolliggate one. Obviously you know making a lot of edgy jokes
while also covering the topic probably isn't the best idea. Um
obviously right but you know the extremely edgy jokes that I
have made back then um like it's >> okay so I can't walk
away quite yet. I can't walk away quite yet. So when she says
edgy jokes, right? And when she says, "Oh, I honed in on edgy
jokes." She means she skinwalked Mr. Girl and then couldn't stand
on business and had was incapable intellectually of thinking
through what his message actually was. So she just thought it
was funny and cool to say you're a And so she did that. She had
none of the backing understanding, none of the backing like moral
grounding at all for why Mr. Girl was doing this. Doesn't get
it.
and
predictably what what happened just predictably follows, right?
She doesn't she's not willing to stand on it. She's not willing
to like play with the jokes or or have the reasons for it. So
when people ask her, she just like says she just says random
bull, right?
But it was just skinwalking Mr. Girl and she I dude there's a
reason he's banned like skinwalking the guy who got banned for
the he said probably not a good idea. There's probably like a
lot of people who actually disagree with that, who think it's
really harmful and it's like an entirely intellectual position
to have to say the things he did, right? It's an entire intellectual
like um exercise to say the things he did for the reasons he
did. If you don't get it, it's very dangerous to just try to
>> It's not like there's any >> Anyway, I'll uh I'm
still be right back. I had to come back and talk through the
Coke that >> also covering the topic probably isn't the
best idea. um obviously right but you know the extremely edgy
jokes that I have made back then um like it's it's not like there's
anything different from these jokes from or like from the things
that Mr. Graph said or like Destiny have said. So I guess the
way I kind of look at it is like back in the day um I was a naive
new content creator and I did not know how to navigate the space.
So I thought that being the most provocative was like the best
way to go.
So, I made a lot of jokes that would get me a lot of negative
attention, but obviously at the time I was naive, right? Like
looking back it was pretty stupid. But but while I was like actually
covering the topic itself, right? Um, okay. But I need to say
PD cuz I don't think YouTube likes it. I don't think YouTube
likes it when I say say that. Okay. It's fake background. I got
you. Yeah, I figured it out. So obviously because of that, right?
And then I also admitted at some point I unironically consume.
So,
also that's more what we're talking about here. Okay. So, when
she says things like, "Oh, well, I joked about this. I joked
about that." Nobody mad about the jokes, dog. Ain't nobody care
about the jokes, dog. Jokes are not the problem. The problem
is the unironic statements you made about your medical conditions
and medical treatment that lead people to believe that you could
be a danger to kids. Uh, basically the incredibly disingenuous
or dishonest statements you made about your medical treatment,
like the idea that a therapist would prescribe that you off to
drawn images of children as much as possible to get over your
OCD.
that the the idea that a trained professional, somebody who took
years and years of their life committed to a field like one discipline
so that they could get a job and then they would go, you know
what, I'm going to throw that all away by recommending to somebody
who was attraction to kids that they off and feed that attraction
as much as
Ain't a single
working professional in the field of therapy who would ever do
that. Who would ever risk you touching a kid and then having
to go stand trial for why they advise you to continue to feed
that compulsion
which sorry the compulsion here would be that you're disgusted
by the idea that you're and so to train you to not be disgusted
that you're they would get you to draw images of kids. That also
makes no sense. That also is totally insane. every single element
of the story she's told factually make no sense. There's no way
she talked to any medical professionals about this. >> If
you don't like the fact that I consume, you're free to leave.
Okay? You know, it like that is just a part of me, you know,
like it's it's not like I can change my attractions or anything
like that, right? But I don't think I'm a I really don't think
so. Like I'm generally attract Yeah, I might be in the minority
here, but I don't know about DJers who still watch this person's
audience. I, by the way, I've kept track of every single person
who's ever come to me and said something about like food shops
doing good content. I keep track meticulously of every one of
you. Okay? I screenshotted it. How much you love this person's
content? Cuz I'm going to say it loud and proud. When somebody
tells me they're not a I want more than a probably.
I want more than a maybe.
I want a hell no. I'm not a I don't want a Well, I'm probably
maybe kind of not a no. No,
>> Attracted to just like it's not like I can change my
attractions or anything like that, right? But I don't think I'm
a I really don't think so.
I don't think I'm a I really don't think so. Hold on. Where's
my Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Now we need to pause cuz I need
my Valor Media seal of approval. Where do I have that? We need
our Valor Media seal of approval. Where is this? Connor, please.
Connor, please. We need to always remind people that Connor was
like, "Oh, I really like food shops." Jtock Alog content. Her
JSTock Alog content's really good. So, this is a this is a Valor
Media approved
creator. We love their content. Okay.
>> Like, I'm generally attracted to just like women in
their 20s, right? Women in their 20s to
uh Yeah. Just in their in the 20s range. That's it. >> Yeah.
I'm I'm like only attracted to grown adult women. Like 25 and
up is what I say. Sometimes I think maybe 30 and up would be
a better idea. Okay. Yeah. Everybody believes you, bro. Everybody
believes you right now. This is totally something that makes
sense with anything else you've ever said. >> I'm 26, so
yeah. I don't know. Like I could never imagine like going after
like a kid IRL. Like it's just not true, I guess. But then at
some point, you know, I addressed the allegations so much.
I addressed the allegations so much to the point where it become
like the Strand effect where it was like, "Wait, what?
how can you address something so much
that it becomes the Stryand effect?" The Stryand effect, which
is the idea that you try to sweep something away, you try to
not address something and it blows up its popularity, right?
But she's addressed something so much that she striand affected
it. Bro, this person, by the way, this is the person that people
are like, this person would tell people, "Oh, Destiny's like
totally innocent. Destiny didn't do anything wrong." And they're
like, "Yes, yes, you're a reliable source of information."
And again, I keep track of these people. I keep track. I keep
track of you, Connor. I keep track. Like, the more I address
the allegations, the more I have to like repeat it over and over
again. And that basically was like lolly gate one, right? That
was lolliggate one. And then it moved on to lolliggate 2 and
logate 3. Loggate one was like um when uh Twitch pole at the
time was
>> Wait, hold on. Why? Why was the lawsuit something that
made it blow up? Evil Johnny Bravo. What was the lawsuit aiming
to do? What was the lawsuit aiming to do? >> And they were
trying to cancel my career. Okay, like cancel my early content
creation thing. Okay, that's it. Not career. There's no career.
And I think Chudlo Logic was the one that really blew up the
thing. And then Counterpoints actually debated Chudlo Logic on
the subject of me at the time like years ago. So, so that's what
formed counterpoints like early kind of like towards me or whatever,
right? You're not attracted to milks. No, I find milks extremely
unattractive. Okay. However, at the same time, like I don't know.
That's just my preferences, you know? Like, what can I say? Yeah,
I like beach babes. Like, that kind of [__] Okay.
Whatever. Um, but like or or not, like the body type, not the
actual archetype. Okay, [__] Never mind. No,
>> this person should not be allowed at the beach. So,
without a I don't know.
Is that a supervisor? I I don't know what to say. Do >> you
have OCD? I do. Um I think at some point um because I felt so
guilty about consuming um I saw therapist for it. And this is
something that people will also bring up as well. And by the
way, okay, I'm only going to address it this one time because
I don't like stryend effect.
She's only going to address it one time.
Still doesn't understand what the stry end effect is because
her only evidence that she ever talked to a therapist about this
was evidence that she clearly produced.
and
and it had nothing to do with POCD, had nothing to do with attraction
to kids. It was just a general conversation with a therapist
about OCD. Only evidence ever produced. Oh, sorry. I believe
there's also a prescription bottle at some point that gets shared
that is like generically for anti-depressants or >> like
this thing. Um basically what it is is that
I became extremely extremely anxious and about like consuming
okay and in general. Okay. I became paranoid because I was like
oh my god
no you had POCD or that was your claim which is the attraction
the fear that you could be a right. Did she just say she was
scared of >> By the way, okay, I'm only going to address
it this one time because I don't like Stryson affecting like
this thing. Um, basically what it is is that
I became extremely extremely anxious and about like consuming.
Okay. And
>> oh, so it's changed entirely. >> Okay. I became
paranoid because I was like, "Oh my god, what if I'm a bad person
for consuming this? What if I'm like a PDF for consuming this?"
Okay. So I was like, "Man, I am. Oh my god, I'm like gaslighting
myself, right? So, I went and saw a therapist. I paid like $200
per hour, by the way. Like out of pocket, $200 per hour because
I was like I was genuinely at my lowest like in terms of um mental
health. So, I went to go see the therapist
and then
um the >> you're ill, American Swag, you're ill. If you
if you're watching the stream in any room where your parents
could see it, you are ill. Okay, I'm I'm sorry. Okay, this is
what you need to do to avoid the compulsions because your compulsion
is
not to
this is going to sound really awkward, okay? But I promise this
is going to make sense because when it comes to OCD, you can't
you have to not do the convulsions. You have to not do the rituals,
okay? You have to avoid
I just realize we're very quickly running out of time on the
stream, guys. If you like the content, go ahead, donate throw
a few subs my way. Donate some kicks, okay? Donate to through
Streamlabs. Anything you got, appreciate it very much. We're
at $30 an hour right now. We
three three subs. Three subs or $15 away for another hour on
the stream. I know we're going to add a lot more hours tonight.
So, I'm comfy. I'm here for the long haul. I'll do another 10
hour stream right now. >> Dare me to I'll do another 10
hours >> at all times. >> The compulsion was to not
do because I would think that would
>> So, obviously what the
spam, thank you for the five gifted. Let's go. Oh, that's another
hour. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Appreciate it, dude.
>> who is an OCD specialist told me to do is that you need
to do the opposite of what your compulsion tells you to do, which
means that no matter what situation it is, and I'm not joking,
and this is the really funny part, okay? I mean, it's really
funny or really weird, okay? They'll be like, >> "Oh, you
know what?
>> Just do it. Do it without guilt. Do it without." Machico,
thank you for the gifted sub. Again, basically,
no no therapist is going to recommend this, right? No therapist
is going to recommend you feed the
element of this to treat yourself or to to teach yourself to
not be attracted to kids. I do not believe any therapist will
say that you need to treat the element. You described it as PCD.
This is a new thing where it's like, "Oh, I was actually scared
of
she had OCD,
negative like um I guess
like phobic OCD about to is the new story to make her previous
therapy story make any sense at all. It's an obvious like shift.
It's an obvious slide of the previous claims to try to make any
of the story connect and make sense in any >> Shame, you
know, and at some point I got better. I finished the whole thing
and I'm like,
you know what? I'm better now. Okay, I'm I'm done. All right,
but obviously like even though I got done with all of the therapy
treatments or whatever, like it still didn't make anything else
go away. Like it still didn't make the drama go away or whatever,
right? So ultimately, I think Licate 2 was me.
The drama here being her admissions of attraction, her admissions
of not being willing to stand on the same side of the street
as a child, right? This would be the the drama the drama of her
make the drama go >> beefing with Keeles. So Keles was
like digging up a bunch of like the old crashs that I was having
during LAate 1.
Was that how you found he had OCD? No, I No, I've had I I think
I've always suspected I have OCD for the longest time as well.
Um, but like that was when um that was when Keeles was like beefing
with me. I know. But when Keeles reconnected her bridge with
DG, that's when I also initially got banned from DG because I'm
pretty sure Katra was the one who um said Kele sends her regards.
I something really cringe. Did you hear that? No. Um I missed
whatever it was. Just messaged me. Suspect OCD for the longest
time.
So I did hear that. Never mind. And I did hear that.
I didn't hear if it was I've suspected or I had suspected.
I'll go back English. >> That was when um was that how
you found out OCD? No, I No, I've had I I think I've always suspected
I have OCD for the
>> I have always suspected I had OCD >> for the longest
time. So that does imply be via just the English alone that she's
never been diagnosed with OCD, right? Like that's pretty obvious.
I didn't pay attention. I thought she said I'd suspected, but
it's I have suspected, which is a little different. I know. I
know. He's 100% never seen a therapist. She had one email from
a therapist about OCD and nothing else. Um, but like that was
when um that was when Keeles was like beefing with me. I know.
But when Keeles reconnected her bridge with DG, that's when I
also initially got banned from DG because I'm pretty sure Call
Matra was the one who um said
Kee sends her regards. I It's something really cringe. Okay.
Basically, Keeles was calling me a PDF while she was actually
probably grooming actual children into becoming trans. It was
super weird. Okay. On her Discord server. So, it's like nice
projection there. Okay. >> I think it was after the grooming
stuff, but yeah. >> So, um yeah. Uh that was Kev. The third
one was when I was having another like debate session with like
commentary. Basically, commentary was honing in on me during
that time and it was their turn. It was their turn to try to
cancel me. Okay. So, just notice how each of the
So, the whole thing has just been disingenuous from the start.
Basically saying that, oh well, all these people took my jokes
and they started trying to hold me accountable for my jokes.
She wasn't joking. She wasn't doing something other than trying
to debate people and crashing out. She posted prescriptions.
She posted like an email with a therapist that did not seem to
claim. So now I'm curious if she just told that therapist she
had a previous diagnosis
or what happened because that there is a conversation about OCD,
right? But you don't go grab a a email from a therapist and a
prescription bottle to try to show people that you have OCD if
you're joking. Right? This wasn't about jokes. It was about your
legitimate statements. The things you tried to tell people were
the truth,
right? To explain your attraction or your fear of attraction.
It it literally changed. There is a quote from a panel she did
with Chud Lonerbox, some other people on it where she said, "I'm
not a I'm like a small people."
So, I'd wonder why she thinks that's a joke.
I listen, I'd have to watch the clip itself to know whether or
not it was a joke. But when you're being sort of like honed in
on and people are saying you're a pedophile, it does seem like
one of two things is true. Either you're happy for people to
call you that, in which case you lean into it and you don't complain
now, or you are genuinely concerned about these things, which
I think is something she's always represented that she is very
concerned >> These different communities have tried to
have their different turns trying to cancel me, right? Essentially,
so first it was Twitch pole or what's left of Twitch pole during
that time cuz it was really dying and and it's pretty much dead
now at this point. like Twitch was pretty much dead. The second
one was Keo's community and that was when she was doing the allegations
uh against like her exartner or some during that time and that
was insane. That was absolutely absurd. And that was also like
that was alo crazy because again I am one person, one incredibly
tiny like magnanimously tiny content creator who is being dogpiled
by an entire community, right? Straight out the gate, dogpiled.
This is all this year. No, two years ago. It started two years
ago. Dogpiled, right, by Twitch and then I was dogpiled by Keles
and her community. Um during this time,
>> all of these communities that didn't necessarily have
a ton of crossover, that weren't necessarily friends, somehow
independently
came all to the same conclusion that this person is probably
a
very very much indicative of a dog pile or a witch hunt, right?
all these independent entities coming to the same conclusion
that this person's likely a
surely nothing they did wrong just totally innocent victim being
dogpiled by evil individuals. Um she was pulling like 3k to 4k
concurrent viewers. Um the first one is also like spearheaded
a little bit by um counterpoints and chloics community right
a little bit. So and then the third one was commentary. So it
was like now recording it was um the commentary community who
wants to have their slice of the pie now. It became pretty popular
to cover me I guess like at some point like at some point it
just became kind of popular to cover me like in that little space.
So that's where I got my >> Counterpoints went back on
it. Yeah, Counterpoints just doesn't have any moral bones in
his body. He was willing to press Chud Logic super hard over
this. He was willing to press and say like Quimma was totally
making this person like a viable influencer. He's He's actually
doing harm in the world.
This is a thing that happened like two years ago. Counterpoints
still in business then, but now when Destiny does it, he's like,
"Well, Destiny does bad things all the time, so I guess I guess
since Destiny does bad things all the time, and I accept that,
why would I get mad about this one?" I do believe he said, "Oh,
I don't want food chops around." But that was after he defended
a bunch of food chops content. Implied that he watched in support
of food chops.
Do you guys not remember Counterpoint saying verbatim? Oh, she
does really good JC Alog content. Well, sure sounds like that's
support from Counterpoint.
And now and now it seems like DG is finally having their turn.
>> Um in terms of coming after me for like this exact same
things. So whenever somebody tells me
whenever somebody tells me, oh, like why don't you address it?
Why don't you address it? Why don't you address it? It's because
we've done this before. like it's Groundhog Day, you know, when
you do the same action over and over again. >> He may have
disavowed at some point after it became clear that they're going
to have another crouch.
I'm curious when Connor was the person who knew that this person
was and Destiny wanted to help have them help uh have her help
him, what did Connor say then? Well, she does really good JC
Alog content was his response. And if you think I'm going to
let that go when he decided that, oh, if it helps my streamer
daddy, I'm going to totally like sweep for this. You think I'm
going to let that go? You are dead wrong. >> But then you
keep on resetting back to like 8 a.m. or some, right? So like
what's going on is that is Dan Gigg. That's true. But like what's
going on is that like for the first one,
I explained myself. I tried to explain myself. I did a really
bad job at it. And then second time and then third time, right?
And I got better and better. I got better and better at explaining
it. I thought they knew already. Only some only some knew,
but now it's like being pushed to the forefront, right? But I
But anyway, it's like I get better and better at explaining it.
I made a less story up each time. Oh, that's cool. We'll listen
to the first story. Listen to you just claiming facts about the
first the first time about your therapy, about all of this. I
don't need to listen to your lies you made up after people really
didn't want to accept you the first time. off >> at some
point. Like in the past when I got these allegations,
I was crashing the out. Like I was a total crash out. Okay.
So, there's going to be a lot of cringe. There's going to be
a lot of cringe that they're probably going to be replaying
in order to like shame me based on that I said like one to two
years ago, which like again, these are like prehiatus times because
after I came back from my hiatus, like I would argue I just became
a straight up a different person. Um because I like joined the
USPS, I delivered mail. Um I don't know. I got a lot of like
outdoor experience and so like it basically
dude this is like straight up. She was like my training arc was
being a mailman. I was a total loser. I was a total loser and
then I was a mailman for 12 months and I am now a fully formed
human.
I now a fully formed human
guys. After being a mailman and getting experience in the real
world, food chops is no longer a it turns out. All the other
stuff, she'll still totally sweep for the previous comments.
She'll never explain any of it correctly, right, or accurately
without lying. But now that she was a mailman,
she's no longer
kind of elevated myself in a way, right? But yeah, just know
that, you know, it's a lot of stupid. But then anyway, I will
now explain, okay, for people who don't know the context, I will
now explain why we have this current drama, okay? Like why um
this current thing is happening. The reason why the current thing
is happening is because I was it all began with the Celeste [__]
but then if you don't know what the Celeste [__]
is, it's stupid. Just like go to my channel and then click on
the responding to Dan thing for the context, okay? like you'll
get all the context there cuz I have a video on it. Um that is
like essentially responding to Dan. Okay. But one of the most
important parts is that all you need to know is that that is
when my beef with Dan essentially began. Dan, >> have you
seen that already? No. I have no idea what she's talking about
here. I don't really care where the source of her beef with Dan
came.
kind of just kind this person is kind of just I'm guessing the
source of her beef with Dan was oh Dan said some mean things
to Destiny or Dan wasn't cool to Destiny at some point I'm guessing
called me up because he got triggered over me like trolling him
in voice chat which is an insane response I guess and
>> I DM' him based off of a friend a mutual friend that
actually really liked Dan um so they were like please give Dan
a chance so I was like okay fine I'll give Dan a chance So, I
DM'd Dan and I was like, "Hey, do you mind deescalating? Like,
we can fight. I think we can fight. I think we can fight. However,
I don't appreciate the pedal jacketing. You can call me. You
can call me whatever, but I don't like the fact that you're calling
me a because that is not true. I don't believe I'm a PDF." Okay.
Again, from my perspective, I'm not saying this in Dan's DMs,
okay? I shouldn't be explaining myself
>> Like, I'm sorry. I should I expect this person to be
treated like an equal to Dan? I'm sorry. Like Dan, for better
or worse, he sweeps, but he has like his own things, his own
opinions. I'm not going to treat this person like they're an
equal. When they came in and just only because everyone else
could see the evidence that Desu clearly like had done a bunch
of really bad [__] and you came in were like, "No,
it's actually not that bad." Just because you came in as a obvious
opportunistic clout chasing,
I'm not going to treat you like a person now. Like you deserve
your own opinion. You do bow down to Dan. You are Dan's cattle.
That's the job you signed up for. Bow down like the cattle you
signed up to be. Okay? Don't give him lip. Just kneel. You loser.
And she didn't do that. She decided she was going to try to have
her freedom. Try to be like a normal person. No, you don't get
that. You don't get to sign up to be cattle and then opt out.
That's not the way this works >> based off of like unsubstantiated,
right? But again, yeah, but >> you guys understand what
I'm saying, right? That she was totally opportunistic. She didn't
have good opinions. She didn't have good analysis of her own.
She had nothing, right? And when when the pu when push came to
shove and she had to be honest about situations, she lied to
keep things better for Destiny. I understand some people would
say that that might be similar to what I did, but it's not. My
was totally different. I brought people on who Destiny didn't
want on his platform at all from the beginning the entire time.
Right. What do food shops do? She just only platformed people.
She basically only platformed jokers or people who were directly
supportive of Destiny. That's it. Cattlem, we prefer [__]
and Chatt. Well, >> but then again, right, like I'm just
>> Whichever way you prefer it, >> here it is, right?
So then what happened is that then I leaked my logs of Dan between
me and Dan onto Twitter. And the reason why I did this is because
Dan started deleting the logs afterwards. He literally started
deleting his own responses to me.
So, like the reason I leaked the logs was because he didn't trust
me to keep the logs there. So, I had to post them on Twitter.
What?
The reason he The reason I saved all the logs and then posted
them to Twitter was because I only saved them first and then
he started deleting them. So, then I posted them to Twitter.
Why? If you had them saved, why did you post them to What What
is the thought process there?
What's the
What? Huh? Instantly afterwards. Um because I don't know. Maybe
he's like
I don't know why he did that, I guess. But I honestly do not
know. Okay. Um I don't get what's the point because he'll just
look bad if like I just repost the deleted messages. So I don't
even know why he did in the first place. I don't know. He's just
kind of stupid. But like he doesn't trust you and it seemed like
that was a good call. Dan's just stupid for not trusting me.
If he just trusted me, I would never violated his privacy.
>> So anyhow, all right. So, I posted it and then and it
just basically showed that he wasn't he said that as long as
you never talk about me ever, I will never call you a That is
insane. That's insane. I'm a person who covers the space. I'm
I'm like a commentator that covers this space. It's an especially
if if you are a player in the space. If you are a player in the
space, I think it's completely unreasonable if you told me that
um oh yeah, you should never ever cover me ever. You should avoid
me at all costs. I think that's a demand and I think that demand
is so unreasonable.
It's only
if you are literal cattle
little goyam chatt that is there to do what destiny asks. If
you have a real purpose, if you serve a real like market need,
if you're if you're helpful to these people, then you could make
demands. You have the ability to make demands. But it sounds
like you made demands of these people and they told you to off,
right? It seems pretty simple. Hey, uh, guys, I'm like important
and you should listen to me. No, you can off. You're not important.
Literally, the only thing you were good for was lying about Destiny's
court case. That's it. That's all you're good for. You're not
entertaining. You're not like coverage of that community that
they want. They don't want to associate with somebody with past
an actual past.
They don't want any of that. You have nothing to offer them.
And I just want to take this opportunity to remind people just
in case you're in that audience, you came from my audience. Never
come back. You're a loser. You have no friends. You decided to
go join this community because you desperately wanted Destiny
to be innocent
yourself in a video game. Yourself in a video game. Okay? Do
not come back here. Do not pass go. Do not collect $200. Just
leave. Just leave this existence. Lean this plane of existence.
Okay,
>> I don't think that's a real demand. That is not a real
demand, right? Because a real demand would be trying to compromise
and trying to meet somewhere in the middle and have a discussion,
right? Which is what I was looking for. But if he gives some
demand like that, I know the message he's sending. The message
he's sending is I don't want to deescalate. I want to escalate,
right? I want to continue this war. So, I want to >> Oh,
hold on. Speaking of Speaking of, you basically wouldn't be able
to cover any streams where he's in VC.
Speaking of can >> like continue doing >> a previous
statement.
>> Um yeah, MBTD says you basically wouldn't be able to
cover any streams where he's in VC. Yeah. Yeah. I I think so.
Yeah. So, which is unreasonable. That's crazy because let's just
say if Dan was debating somebody else, right? If Dan was debating
somebody else and it was really really good content. Really,
I can't commentate on that. like I just straight up can or maybe
he means like I should never criticize him just so so then my
channel in which other people watch for honest and reliable information,
right? >> Yeah. My channel people watch for honest and
reliable information. Well, we'll see if that's true. If it's
for honest and reliable information, then I'm guessing you can
disconnect from the DG sphere and totally carry on and be fine,
right? What I expect to have happen is her to gravel at Dan's
feet, at Destiny's feet, for as long as it takes to be accepted
back in whatever role they're they dame to give her and to put
the cattle collar back on
of her own valition
and to just gravel and accept Dan's orders. That's what I expect.
>> a lot of people do watch me to get like drama news about
Destiny, right? like drama news about destiny which is like they
they try to treat my you know coverage as like the the the best
the best coverage right so you're telling me that if Dan gets
included like I can't cover anything negative compared to I feel
like it would
again
um I don't know how to tell you this
Destiny has you know finally two people back Mutin and Dan who
were decent orbiters okay they're hanging out in his VC and a
predicate of them hanging out and not casting destiny back into
the hell where it's just food shops, zip zip, and cfka, okay?
Where it's not just those people.
Part and parcel with that is adhering to mutin and Dan's demands,
which is no allowed except Destiny. Uh, not actually is Destiny
has, you know, he's in a fee file or something. It's fine. It's
fine. It's fine. It's fine. He just retains child. He's not a
Okay. So, Jesus. Careful, careful, careful. Don't want to don't
want to throw anything out there that I shouldn't be able to
back up. Couldn't be able to back up. Okay. Anyway, their demand
is outside of present company, no allowed. That's what the rules
are. Okay. That include that. That means you, man. That means
you get out. >> Damage my integrity in the space. Okay.
So, so yeah. Um, complete unreasonable demand. So, obviously
that's why I escalated it. It's very cringe. I don't know. He
literally, >> by the way, just on a fundamental level,
we're nowhere near explaining why she said it was cool to do
and SWAT Dan and his family, right? Like, none of this even comes
close to making sense when it's like, okay, but you did say it's
cool to do and swat Dan's family, right? Could you answer me
why you thought that was a cool thing to say? >> Meant
don't.
>> Even if in some insane universe where you tried to play
that off as a joke, why would you joke? That's like over the
line. That's obviously over the line.
That's over the line in the exact like, "Okay, we got to put
go put Lenny down kind of way, right?
That's it." Like, that's it's like, "Okay, I I understand. You
may not have the capacity to understand why that's a okay joke.
You might be kind of, but you killed a bunch of bunnies and you
got to go. We got to put you down, bud. Sorry. You killed a woman."
Actually, he'd been killing bunnies the whole time. You killed
a woman. Okay. You actually You actually up now. at all. I think
he just meant don't disparrage him. If he meant don't disparrage
him, he would have said so. But it's very clear to me that he's
not treating the conversation seriously. That's it. Right.
>> Isn't it obvious that Dan and Mutton are around solely
for money? That was my thoughts on mutin. But some people said
no on in terms of Dan. Dan got money. Dan got more money than
he could do anything with. Dan's here for clout. Dan's here to
live vicariously through Destiny's community. Dan is not here
for money. Dan's got all the money he ever needs. Dan literally
is retired. He's done. He doesn't need more money. >> Because
I wish you were right, but that's not what he said. Right. I'm
going to read what you said and I'm not going to like Yeah,
because
it just makes no sense. It makes no sense. Like, would you not
try to talk carefully around that? I don't know. I don't think
the burden of interpretation should be up to me. Right. The the
best part is man I was just thinking back to that stuff last
night when when Pisco asks Destiny like doesn't Dan like operate
in your community and then Destiny's like no like when he starts
talking about his is like crusade
and immediately
shouldn't it be wait why is he selling his crusade in your community
which is what he did from the beginning to recruit your community
to go on his crusade with him right but the idea that Dan is
like not involved that was really funny to me >> the burden
should be up to the person was trying to carefully word their
response. I'm just saying. So,
um, now I guess what happened is that like I made like a uh driveby
call in into Destiny's room to like
uh essentially uh troll Dan. Yes, I did troll Dan. It It was
just to It was actually to provoke him and to annoy him on purpose.
Okay. But I don't think it was anything that was actually But
it >> Hold on. We might be getting details. I believe Dan
has said he would never deescalate after the threats to his family.
Is this implying that there's been a deescalation after the threats
to his family?
Oh no. Oh no. Oh no.
Dad may have fallen
I just got given a link to some more content here >> after
because I was banned from DG chat by this moderator named Mitch.
And after I got banned from DG Chat um for like a day only. So,
I didn't really give a um for only like a day, Dan essentially
said I heard that Dan said, "Good job, Mitch. You get a gold
star." >> No, no, no, no. But like not in not so different
from the way that
food chops is is the cattle of Dan. Dan also has to bend down
for for Destiny. When when Destiny says something is the way
it is, Dan is lucky in that he basically has a you know a a king
of the kingdom who is too avoidant to ever make a decree. So
Dan gets to make all the decrees he wants. But occasionally the
king will say no no you have to do this and Dan does have to
listen. Dan is below destiny in the hierarchy. So if Destiny
does make a decree like you have to be friends with this Dan
reluctantly will listen. Even if the threatened his family he
will listen. So it was Dan who attacked first again. Right. It
was Dan that provoked me again first. Right. And I'm pretty sure
Dan has dropped tons of accusations in DG chat before that as
well. So, and I ignored all of these. I ignored all of these
because I was like, you know what? I'm not going to fall for
it. Okay? I'm not going to give into hate. I'm not going to give
into anger, whatever. Right? >> So, um like in that instance
specifically, I'm a very angry person. Okay? In general. Anyway,
the point is is that he struck first again. Okay? Like cuz he
has no shame. Okay, he has no shame. So he struck first again.
>> Curious how these Israelis always seem to do it. I left
my entire air force on the airfield and suddenly it's gone. GOD
DAMN YOU ISRAELIS. GOD DAMN. By complimenting someone for banning
me and Zip Zip in DG chat. Okay. Um so then I went into
uh the voice chat and I said and I said, "Yeah, no, no, no."
It goes while video was playing. But at the same time, it's like,
yeah, I I think I have the right of confrontation if you're going
to say that in DG chat, right? If you're a specific person and
you say something like that, I think I have the right of confrontation.
Okay. I I understand you're trying to steal man Dan here. Okay.
But trust me, he is a very spiteful person. Okay. Anyway, how
Okay, here's >> Oh, that's a horrible thing to say, Canadian
caller. And completely
in line with every reality we've we've actually gotten to peer
into. So, >> yeah. Although, yeah, hold on. Wait, Gummy
Verse raises an excellent point. You think she would refuse?
>> Okay, he should get his chance. So, what I did was that
I entered um Destiny voice chat and I essentially said, "Dan,
I heard that I heard from Zip Zip that you were talking." Okay.
And there was no immediate reply. Um and I was like, "Oh, yeah,
that's what I thought." And I left. Right. So, that was what
I did to piss him off. Yes, I didn't allow him room to reply
there, but like mainly in my opinion, like I just wanted to call
him out and then just leave, you know? That's it. I don't want
to overstay my welcome there. So, so that was a troll. That was
genuinely I was trolling him. Okay. Again, make it very clear
I was trolling him. Okay. So, because and and by the way, am
I not right to troll him because he complimented someone for
banning me? If he's going to say something like that, then yeah,
of course I have the right to troll him, right? So, after I trolled
him, um he then spent
and and this is the ultimate event, okay? He then spent the entire
like a large section of the Anything Else podcast
on me.
>> I have to start speeding this up a little bit. >> He
then spent
>> this is what we had already watched. Okay. Honestly,
it's then you know what? I'm going to drop one. I don't give
a
>> Oh, sorry. She does come through here and she goes,
"Guys, actually, I've only done things that was defending the
same thing. Take a look. I don't know. This is about to be the
hottest take. Am I about to drop a hot take about thousand-y
old spirits? Just find this for people don't know. You know what?
I am going to drop one. I don't give a [__] People
that obsess over like people that watch. Who the [__]
cares? They're [__] cartoons, bro. Who cares? Why
are you so I think I think
>> this take certainly wasn't motivated by some anime avatar
woman he was at that exact moment in time. Sure. Surely not.
Surely couldn't just be that.
>> Wait, what year is this? Was it Rose specifically? Hold
on. What year was it? I can't remember the year on this clip.
God damn. >> And now that we've learned that projection
is real, because it obviously is. I think the most likely place
to find are the people that are online constantly seeing on everything.
I think they're the most likely to be where you'll some guy will
be like, "Wait a second. Did you look at kid in Disney World
when you were at Disneyland?" He was talking about them, right?
Like no dog. Actually, like I see kids all the time. I don't
think about Yeah, I think that would be really absurd. But when
somebody says that they're a when somebody says they have an
attraction to children, they're they have and they think it's
POCD instead of okay, they say those things like I have an attraction
to kids and it like drives terror in me. Okay, they say those
things, but then they don't describe any real treatment for that
POCD. They describe like fake treatment. They can't back up that
they've had treatment. They generally fail to to give like any
way they've tried to treat it. We start to ask questions. Yeah,
we start to ask questions. It's kind of weird that you would
like It's kind of weird that you would think that I would though.
Is that like a Is that like a thing that you think about a lot
if you like see a kid? Does your mind instant like you have 15year-olds
in your Discord server? I bet you try to them and send nudes
to them and get nudes from them and you over everything they
say in chat, don't you? The time like no, not actually, dog.
No, that you know that man, it sounds like you got some firsthand
experience. Like, >> did he have like a roundabout way
of trying to defend having 15year-olds in the court or
that's really that was a really bizarre specific thing to talk
about? No, man. Sometimes there are people there are people that
go like really overboard sometimes when they like point out like
that guy's a like how do you know he's a he drives right next
to a grade school on his way to work every morning and there
are other routes that you can take like okay is that that's it
for you that's the line that's how you know like Jesus I don't
know man because I've like now I've seen so many funny story
food shops might avoid the route by the the school okay cuz she's
so terrified that she'll touch a kid she gets anywhere >> I've
seen so many cases of projection before where people like project
like this insane I hate that this meme is real I hate that this
meme is real but how many guys do this where it's like I respect
women's rights And then they get me too and it's like so John
THE UH
OH MY GOD THAT was prophetic right there. Holy sh Oh no no. Oh
the guy that logged in you know two weeks ago. [__]
Rewind. We heard that right. Like I respect women's so many cases
of projection before where people like project like this insane.
I hate that this meme is real. I hate that this is real. How
many guys do this where it's like I respect women's rights blah
blah blah and then they get me too and it's like so John the
SJW
understand the guy that logged in you know two weeks ago tried
to [__] into my when I stayed over his house and
I told no like 27 times you like it feels like there's some feels
like the projection might be real you know I don't know I just
I'm just saying
you don't say
now I recognized the apartment from the Bob 7 manifest was this
before or after it became clear that he had disrespected Belina's
consent and was sending videos of her to young women
was this before or after that I actually don't know in This quote
is from
be really funny if it was from before. It's still really funny
if it was after
>> curious. Some people online >> have this like
really unhealthy
>> with like hunters talking about where
they'll just be like they just scream about it. They're just
so crazy about it. It's like damn dude you got to have other
things to think about. Maybe maybe not. So, it's kind of crazy
to me. Like, in my opinion, it's kind of crazy to me that like
Dan's like one of Dan's closest friends, like Steven is like
has this opinion, but I don't ever see Dan seriously contending
with Destiny on it. Like, maybe they'll joke about it like once
or twice, I'm sure, but I've never seen a single argument or
debate between them about something like this. And even though
like Dan seems to be more than happy to try to hone in on the
PDF allegations. There's also another clip out there
that doesn't make any sense. Again, none of this makes any sense
because Jobs has described actual attraction towards kids. she
has described actually having to go to therapy or saying she
went to therapy. And then when she describes the therapy, it
is obviously a therapy nobody would recommend. And now she's
had to change the story multiple times to try to like adjust
facts for the obvious criticisms of her fake story from before.
>> There's also another clip out there of Dan saying that
people shouldn't throw around PDF allegations loosely. >> Oh,
also, yeah, if this person was useful to Dan in some way, he
wouldn't care that they're at all. Like, if this person helped
Dan accomplish a goal, Dan believes that this person is harmful,
right? that they're never going to help accomplish any goal that
he has or Destiny has. That's why he's getting rid of you. That's
why he doesn't want you around. He thinks you're useless. Not
because you're the thing is just like a a helpful coincidence
for Dan, right? Like he didn't get rid of forethought because
he didn't like that forthought was misogynist. That wasn't why
he got rid of forthought. He got rid of forethought because he
had a petty squabble with forethought and wanted to [__]
him over. Right? Like Dan operates in the most like self-s serving
of ways at all times. He doesn't have principles. He's not principally
against here. He's not principally against He's just going to
virtue signal about it to get rid of you obviously
without much evidence, right? Like, oh, people shouldn't be throwing
around these things loosely. Bro, you're the one doing it. By
the way, he was saying that to Finn, Stephen, okay, which I mean,
fair enough. I agree with that. Okay, however, you're a hypocrite.
Okay, like you're contradicting yourself. All right, which is
why like in my opinion, it's like you are so you are so loweffort
drama. Like, you are actually like a loweffort drama monger.
Like unironically like you are not putting in any effort into
this which is why like
oh thank you sleepy but hey uh if you're a mod here don't ban
don't kill friends in the kick chat. Let him be in the kick chat.
What the [__] Again it's just like
thought was right about Kelly though ahead of his time. >> Yeah
but I mean the things he got cancelled for with regards to Kelly
are actually like totally deranged things to say to somebody.
Uh he might have been right right he might have been right about
like the content of her character. Give him that one. But it
wasn't about it wasn't helpful to say the things he >> dude.
Like why would you ever say like this when I can literally dig
up so many clips of you saying stupid all the time. Like why
would you ever do this? It's like it's like Ethan Klein. You
just don't learn. And you're also act like Ethan Klein which
is ironically the funniest part, right? Again, it's the Ethan
Klein penalt thing like over and over again, right? And then
not only that, like um >> um it's five bucks for like the
the tax on those timeouts by the way. $5. So >> I guess
Dan also like calls people pedal all the time as a joke. Um but
here's the thing. I don't think that's acceptable. I don't think
that's okay. Okay. Like there are some things that you can joke
about, but if it's regular in the space, I think that's fine,
but I think you have to be kind of careful. Like for example,
I I would I don't allow people to joke about other people being
a PDF um uh in my ginga in my server, right? Um like I would
never I would never
That's like a subtle ban on everybody from around my parts. That'sed
up, dude. That'sed up.
That would be like me saying I would never allow people with
PFPs in my Discord. That essentially bans all the people from
food chopses. That's like discrimination through another means.
What the >> like do something like that, you know? Like
I I don't support it. We're very edgy. We're extremely edgy.
>> Okay. Oomphie is back. >> All right. Oomphie,
you're fine.
Now it would be very gighat if he came back and said, we're extremely
cool. We don't do that. We do not do that. Okay. So, yeah. I
don't know. This is like very perplexing to me, I guess. Oh,
yeah. People are saying um people are saying like, "Oh my god,
are you surprised that you got banned from uh DG Perms or something?"
I'm not complaining. I'm not surprised either. I accept stoism.
Okay. I think I Yeah, obviously if I annoy Steven, obviously
he's going to take away my terms. Okay. Yeah, I'm okay with that.
Like I'm not going to blame anybody for like taking away perms
for a completely understandable reason. Okay. Anyway,
um so
I guess like I don't know. It's just it's just so cringe. Um
I don't know. Like this is also very low effort like once again,
right? Um Oops. Wait, why would you criticize Steven? You've
done nothing but defend him and you got your perms taken away
for
what? Well, if it depends on what you got your perms taken away
for. If they got taken away cuz you threatened this guy's kids,
that's that's pretty up. I do I do agree with that. I have a
feeling they were just taken away cuz somebody wanted to take
them away before and now Destiny just doesn't want to defend
you. >> Oops. Sorry, that was bad. Love that vibe. Londo.
Sorry. Right. Okay. Let me think about what else is there. I'm
sure like they're going to make a lot of bad faith characterizations
of me. Um,
so it's just so strange. Just so strange. Boom. I don't know.
That's it. Anyway, >> oh yeah, I want to clarify that both
times it's Dan's fault. Okay. It's like both times Dan's fault.
That is the full context of the situation. Okay. So, whatever
Dan says, that's the full context. Okay. Make sure to um correct
him. All right. >> See, pull that pull that up. Pulling
up in a browser source. I see. >> All right. Content time.
Oh, one last thing. Okay. >> That's a lot of preamble for
like three clips that they play. Like, honestly, this segment
is so boring. Why did you need a longer preamble than the four
minutes of content they produce here? You need like a 30-minute
preamble for the four minutes of content they're about to produce.
Not a good indicator at all. >> Cut this part out. Okay.
Um, let's promo. Okay. Oh, it was just Was it really just taken
away because she was screaming? That's >> I'll see you
guys in a tiny tiny bit. Okay. Because he was tilt and he was
getting annoyed. No, I'm okay with that. Like, whatever. It's
okay. I I'll get it back. I'll get it back. I'm having a hard
time agreeing with you there on mud. It's okay. You don't have
to agree with me. Like, in my opinion, you don't have to agree
with me. You just have to understand my perspective, right? That's
it. Like, in my opinion, you you don't have to agree with me.
Okay. It's fine. All right. I understand. Okay. It's a hard thing
to ask for someone to agree with me straight up, right? Especially
about such a weird subject. So, like I'm not asking for a disagreement
type. I'm asking for asking for understanding and for hearing
me out. That's it. Okay. All right. Hold on. Promo. Hey, if you
enjoyed the content, I got more for you. It's up on YouTube if
you want to.
What does he do? Spends an entire segment on anything else. Okay.
Or pediat. All
>> Did Dan do more content that I'm unaware of? Cuz like
I swear to God, it's like 4 minutes of stuff that they >> just
want to be very clear on what the escalation is. Okay. So again,
5 seconds of me trolling Dan
and he escalates it to an entire segment PDF Jack. >> Before
this, you called him a That's like a bann chat. Has been for
as long as I've been around there, right? You know the ban meme
of like don't call Dan don't insist that he is not allowed around
schools, right? You can't do that. That's like not allowed. >> And
by the way, I'm not even talking about like I'm not even talking
about like Dan participating in Jes
to to complain about me. If you guys don't know, Dan apparently
is like
>> This is so funny.
Listen, we don't we never talk about Hawaii.
This is really funny to me just from the line of thinking that
like it's I listen. Yeah, we we plotting out here. Okay, get
the get dude. Every single time there's just like
I've heard that he might be in con he might be in cahoots with
J-Tock. Don't Don't listen to him. This is like all of these
skits in a room worried about worried about JTO is about to show
up. Okay, what information did they get from JTO? What's going
on? What >> did again in JTO's Discord server because they
hate me. So, he is finding like camaraderie camaraderie with
his best friend's anti-fans
for their hatred on me. What a great friend. Am I right? What
a fantastic friend. Um, but yeah, it's really
uh No, this isn't true. Kickuds. Um, Destiny's the Keles in this
case. I'm the person who's like I think you need like proof to
start trying to like dox me or deplatform me,
right? I'm the person who's like I think you should have a standard
here.
>> So, they're they're the types. >> Weird. I guess
it's like why would you do that? Anyway, and by the way, yes,
there is evidence for all of this. Okay. Um, just go to my first
video on Dan. Um, and then you'll see the receipts. All right.
I'm just saying. Okay. Anyway, was a troll talking about his
kids and wiping dogs? No, that's a that's before that. The kids
and wiping dogs part. I thought >> Oh, hold on. Hold on.
Um, and then you'll see the receipts. All right. I'm just saying.
Okay. Anyway, was a troll talking about his wiping dogs. No,
>> your Princess Zoe says, "Yeah, him going to JTalk."
>> That's before that.
>> That's a That person, Hold on. Just to be clear, your
princess that person was not assigned female at birth. Okay,
I'm sorry to take a shot like that, but that I I would bet so
just any amount of money. Okay, obviously the >> kids are
wiping docs part. I thought it was fair only because um >> a
martini shaken not stirred. >> I know it's a bit off topic,
but I hyped your video recently and was curious how that affects
it and if and how it shows >> Yo, Big Gabriel, thank you
so much for the $5. No, nobody thinks it's you, Zoe. Nobody thinks
it's you. >> How that affects and if and how it shows >> No,
that's not that. >> What do you mean by that? I I I don't
know what that means. I'm sorry. Um, yeah, Dan Fish. Oh, yeah.
By the way, thank you, Meu once again for the 20 sterling. I
appreciate that. >> What did she say? What did she say
about >> Also, another thing. Yes, I did talk like unhinged
[__] about Dan. Okay, I did. And I will own that.
>> No, you didn't talk unhinged about Dan. That's the problem,
right? That's the problem. It's so easy for everybody to understand.
He didn't talk unhinged [__] about him. >> Reason
why I own that is because I gave him the option of deescalation.
He rejected that option and instead he escalated it. Right. His
his offer was completely non-serious and a complete escalation
in my opinion. So in my opinion, yeah, I have no
I She was basically forced to threaten his kids. She was basically
forced to say his kids and wife deserve to be
She was forced to when Dan said, "Don't talk about me." She was
forced to say that his wife deserves harassment from Kiwi farmers
and that his kids and wife deserve to be doxed and harassed and
swatted. That was like obvious. Isn't it obvious to you guys
that that had to happen? Isn't that ob Isn't it incredibly obvious
that that had to happen and there was just no other option? No
reason not to go full nuclear, right? If he's gonna go full nuclear
and call me a PDF, which is like one of the worst things you
can do online to another content creator, then yeah, in my opinion,
I I don't have to hold anything back.
Is that Oh my god, that's like the worst thing you could do online
to another content creator. Is it? Are we sure about that? Cuz
if that's the case, where is my rile DM?
Oh, there it is. If that's the case, why
Oh, I don't have the clip of her saying she's a Oh, well, why
why is she calling herself a Okay, like I think I >> Well,
we will see if we're not 100% sure that they've been burned yet.
I do believe Destiny will try to save them because as Dan has
pointed out multiple times, Destiny thinks this person is useful
to them as like a propaganda arm, right? I would I would ask
food shops, why do you think nobody with any amount of reputation,
not even Mr. Moot, is going to come out and do the same things
you do? Why do you think nobody who has anything to lose will
say the things that you say? Why do you think Destiny thinks
you're important in that way and that way alone?
There's a couple things >> every single every single step
here I've been completely reasonable. Okay. So obviously I'm
going to say the most unhinged because he's also like going full
unhinged. And he also describes to me that he's going to be full
unhinged. So it's like
yeah of course right like duh. Yeah. Anyway. >> Yeah. That
was that was me last night when I was in voice with Steve and
someone joined at the same time and uh >> he's been in
there more after his little crash out. Oh yeah. So I guess Okay,
so this is Dan. So this is Dan in J Stokes Discord server. I
guess like even more so like what what like what is he doing
in there? Like seriously maybe like I was asking has he been
been in there? Oh, I I don't know. I honestly don't know. But
>> yeah, Dan's never left. Dan's just been there the whole
time.
I the more shocking thing you may come to realize is that Dan's
actually Dan was actually in spicy chat forever through all of
Destiny's fights with them. Stay in spicy chat the whole time.
Oh my god. It's almost like he tries to operate as his own person.
>> I think I have birdies who are willing to tell me. Okay.
Anyway, >> birdies who are willing to tell me it's a public
Discord. You could just join and look it up yourself. You could
just make an account and look it up yourself. These people are
like, "Oh, I'm so sneaky. I can get logs from another Discord."
that's public and has a vanity URL that's incredibly predictable.
You aren't you aren't spies. You're not sneaky. You go to public
channels in public places.
It's not it's not sneaky. There's literally a search there's
literally a search function for all of the things you could possibly
want. >> My perfect online
>> I think they're banned, but like there they can just
make a different account, >> I would 10 times be more concerned
at least
return by the way. Okay, for people who are saying okay sorry
mixed life, okay, I appreciate you. Okay, I appreciate you hearing
me out. However, I will say that >> I hear you, but I think
calling for someone to get doxed and spotted is a bit large and
of an escalation past PDF.
Well, I understand she's about to respond to that. Well, I understand
you mixed your life. I understand that. Think about it this way.
Think about >> You can 100% like if you call somebody a
PDF online and I've already been doxed, someone can definitely
swap me. I'm just saying someone can definitely swap me because
if they feel strongly enough about Dan calling me a PDF 100%.
Is so she thinks by Dan calling her a
does that so she's saying that means she's going to get swatted.
So she called for the swatting on him defensively. This is where
the defensive doxing argument takes you.
Oh my god. Oh my god. That's where it takes you. You hate to
see it. It's it's defensive calls for swatting now guys. We've
escalated. The defensive conduct knows no bounds.
>> Like I don't even need to go into that. So obviously
if I like if I say crazy unhinged about Dan about Dan, his kids,
and his wife, it's fair game. >> You bring me to the surface,
risk me to dangerous. It's fair game. Okay, you did it first.
All right. >> Oh god. I just don't know what to say when
they're in here. It's like ah, you know, just >> about
Dan, about Dan, his kids, and his wife. It's fair game,
This is maybe the dumbest thing I've ever say. I thought call
I thought calling for it was dumb in the first place. I didn't
realize they doubled down on
they doubled down
on the calls against Dan's family. They were like, "Oh, I'm justified
in doing that." And then now apparently Dan called for like a
ceasefire or they're having a ceasefire or something.
She's basically like, "Yeah, I should be able to go after Dan's
family." So Dan broke. Oof. I didn't expect Dan to break. We'll
see. >> You bring me to the surface, risk me to dangerous.
It's her game. Okay. You did it first. All right. >> Oh
god. >> So Dan is saying because of the calling this person.
Sorry. Food Chop is saying because Dan called her, she gets to
go after his wife and kids. Very interesting. Very, very cool.
Food Chops has nothing to lose. Dan having a piss off wife can't
be a thing. Um, I mean, his wife's probably never going to know
about it or be able to discern it from any other online harassment.
I think this is hilarious
cuz realistically,
I'm going to be honest, I sometimes I lie just a little bit,
okay? Sometimes I I just do a little scheming, okay? We do a
little plotting. I don't seriously think Destiny's going to let
this person go when he still has his case going, okay? I don't
think Destiny's going to honestly let this person leave. He'll
like totally go, "Oh, that was bad. My bad. Oh, my bad. I'll
unban you and you give her perms back. But if she just keeps
doubling down on like, "Oh, no. I was totally justified in going
after Dan's family."
I think that could end up going actually badly. So, we'll see.
>> I just don't know what to say when they're in here.
It's like ah, you know, >> like, have you seen how predator
hunters hunt like
like
PDFs or or people that they think are PDFs? Not only do they
like it's completely crazy. It's insane. >> I'm good, fam.
I just I don't even want to I don't go after
to them, you know?
>> That's it. It's the
>> I I I blame this I blame this on an entire generation
of growing up watching Chris Hansen. Okay. I blame Chris Hansen.
All right. I blame Chris Hansen for raising an entire like two
generations worth of like unhinged people like Dan. Okay.
>> And by the way, okay, hold on. Wait, wait. I I don't
think those people in Chris Hansen were innocent. I think that
was like literally trapping total. The problem with pedal hunters
is they don't really do a lot of due diligence. I think Chris
Hansen pretty much all of those guys had like pages of DMs wanting
to [__] a 15-year-old and bringing alcohol and rope
and tape and like I'm pretty sure all of those kids were in if
those kids existed, they were in actual danger. For anybody wondering
why so much PDF allegations are like coming out like during this
century,
>> it's because of Chris Hansen. Okay, Chris Hansen ruined
a lie. Yeah, he affected the entire culture in my opinion. But
yeah, >> I want to throw
>> I want to throw out here real quick, Steve. One second
again. Um, >> does Destiny know about all this? Especially
Dan snarking in Jox's Discord server. You should message Destiny.
Ask him if you could have a chat about all this stuff or just
link him to your VOD from today explaining all this stuff. My
god. My god. >> Look at him. He's waiting. >> Okay.
Yeah. Sorry. Last thing. Okay. Um I don't know Zip Zip super
well. Okay. But I have no issue with him. However, this is a
strategy that the unnamed one uh from the previous meme is continually
trying to do because they're desperately trying to latch on to
someone else. Be like, "Ah, Destiny is or sorry, Dan is against
this person and this person." >> No, I have no problem
with Zipo. Nope. No. I don't think >> the unnamed one like
remember you know how I said that people were scared of me and
how people like
didn't want to mention me and and I don't know sometimes I'm
like thinking to myself am I like delusional? Like am I thinking
that like am I thinking that people are just like
am I thinking that I have a bigger like presence than I actually
do or something?
But then
Dan is here on anything else calling me the unnamed one, which
makes me think that all of my
I think that's just literally because he doesn't like like associating
with Dan tried to convince me to go after food shops, right?
Like Dan was like, "You should you should take this person out.
They suck." And I'm like, "No, you can take out your own then."
I love that Destiny's best friend is a That makes my that makes
my life way funnier. Okay. that Destiny is getting an actual
to run interference for him. That's super funny to me.
Okay, that's super funny. I I love that you all have to hang
out with a and pretend that it's fine. But you all hanging out
in a VC with a and playing games together and pretending you're
all big happy family. That's awesome. That's hilarious.
Okay. And I know you specifically now especially because you
said it, but I knew before that how awkward you feel sitting
there in a VC with them having to associate with them. Okay,
I know how that feels and it's funny. So you could take out your
own. Okay, but Dan wanted me to fight with them under the opaces
of oh I just don't want to deal with this at all. I don't want
my name attached to them in any videos. I do not want to be around
any whatsoever.
I'm like no no you can you can take out your own problem. Okay,
I think >> prior assumptions are are are validated. Why
PeaceCo avoids saying my name? Why um why Hutch these days like
he tries to avoid and stuff like that? I mean, if I have that
kind of reputation behind the scenes, then yeah, like I'm not
surprised, right? The unnamed one. That's crazy. >> That's
a little too >> And they're very sneakily trying to attach
that uh to every next. It's going to be Radiant, who, you know,
can redeem himself. You know, he's been a very good sport. I'll
say that. So, very good. All right. Very good sport so far. Even
though I know there's like By the way, this is a little kind
of weird as well is because like I don't think any of these orbiters
require Dan's validation to be approved in DG. This is a little
bit because Dan is like kind of taking the reigns of being like
the leader of DG or something. Kind of weird, but okay, whatever.
Do what you want. Right. But like it's like, oh, like these people
can redeem themselves.
>> Dan unfortunately
normally has a good idea of like how things work. He normally
knows that Destiny's super avoidant and he can just take over
and do what he wants. that Destiny will just crawl up into a
ball and like let Dan do whatever he wants. So if he just bans
you, if he just gets someone to ban you, he knows there's a 90%
chance Desty just off and doesn't say anything. So you could
say, "I don't have to listen to Dan, but they can they can redeem
themselves in my eyes. They can do it. Okay, just try a little
harder." And they're able to redeem them. Like >> can you
stop being like are you okay? Like Jesus like like this is like
a power trip fantasy, you know? >> No, there's some animosity
and there's still some stuff to learn, but still he's been a
good sport about it. He hasn't turned to no. Okay, so that's
that said, >> dude. I wonder if I have my This guy's asking,
"Remember forthought. I wonder if I have my DMs where I'm like,
"Okay, Dan, you're going about this all wrong. Okay, you're going
about this all wrong. Here's what you would have to do if you
actually wanted to go after this guy. Not that I'm telling you
to, but if you actually want to go after him, here's how you
would have to do it." And then I just gave him the the whole
plan, okay? I just gave him like how he would go about doing
it, exactly how you phrase it. And then he like started going
after Forethought, realized he was losing and pulled out the
exact the exact directions and followed them like a recipe. Very
funny stuff. >> he's like you're on this by yourself. You
ain't got no friends. Okay, you you you fight your own battle.
Stop trying to drag someone else down with you. Okay, that's
you. >> Sorry. Go ahead, Steve. >> I like Well, hold
on. I like Radiant. I think they're a lot of fun. They're funny
and they haven't
>> Orthod did try to kill you, though. Yeah, but like in
retrospect, what was the bad thing he did?
It wasn't even like compared to anyone else compared to like
the that's now happened. It's like nothing, right? What was the
recipe? Oh, it had to do with those Kelly Gene logs and just
reading those Kelly Gene logs and asking why he said the things
he did. Why did you say that you hoped that one of Kelly Jean's
only fans Oilers would pay her to a dog? Fore thought. Why did
you say that? That seems like probably a little over the line.
No. Why did you say that you hoped that you wished that for her?
Don't you think that's a little too far for thought? Don't you
think that's a
cause, you know, any crazy issues. They are good. >> They
are the arbit, >> bro. The uname one is still kind of wide.
Okay, I can't get over that part. The unnamed one. I'm taking
it. >> That sounds cool as sometimes the best names are
given by your end. >> The cube UBI thing was something
for the ages. Like, >> sure, but it's funny. Uh, Zip Zip
is fine. I just think he joins sometimes and talks too much,
but the same can be said for me, I guess. Well, the same can
be said for many, many, many, many, many >> It is a skill
that you learn to know when to shut the [__] up.
And I think I've honed the skill pretty pretty easily. Uh, example,
yesterday I just left when he was watching the Desh debate because
I knew that he needed to form content a little bit. So, I [__]
food drops. I just he just mentioned the name. I don't like him
BECAUSE THEY COME AND THEY [__] scream like a [__]
Okay. Thankfully, she has recently
I just want to say that has happened once. Okay. Um, I I don't
know why Mr. Mutton is saying this as if it's like as if it happens
all the time. I'm not joking. It has happened once like like
at this point. Now, it has happened twice. Now, it has happened
twice. And honestly, I would do it again. Okay. If I still had
perms. If I still had perms. Okay. I I will do it again. Okay.
But the thing is is that like I only did it once at this point
of of their recording. Once once and like I
gota find this Listen, someone sent me like a >> I don't
know why you keep saying she. There you go. We're using our pronouns.
You No one here is misgendering food shops. It's not happening.
>> I I didn't say he one time. >> We're not >> Are
they detective? Even if we don't like them, we're still going
to use their pronouns. You >> We're uh I sent an imager
thing. I'm looking for it now. Um hold on. Standby. Who would
I have sent this to? Someone. >> Hold on. >> I said
M, not him. M as in them. You >> This is the dankst dungeon.
>> Misaki, thank you so much for the 10 gifted subs on
kick. Remember, every dollar donated to me is another dollar
donated towards hating Dan. Justifiably, okay? Dan is like one
of the most justifiably hated people. Okay? In my opinion. All
right? Remember, okay? I'm always on the side of light, okay?
I'm always on the side of goodness, okay? And we will crush the
evil. We will crush the darkness. Okay? Thank you so much for
attend.
>> Always on the side of goodness, guys. Don't listen to,
you know, don't pay any attention to the fact that he called
me a on a stream one time and then I said his wife and kids deserve
to get doxed and swatted, you know, but we're always on the good
side. We're literally always on the good side. Okay.
>> Oh god, >> you're literally >> Hold on.
I'm think I'm think I'm >> you can listen to how I say
them all the time. I say M. I say Oh, I really like them. Um
I don't really like them. Not um you guys are actually [__]
when it comes to this pronoun [__] >> You know,
it's not good enough. Uh I'll find these clips.
>> I don't have them on camera right now. So basically,
>> yes, I am. I am a
which is which is a joke. Okay, just so you know, people do this
in DG chat all the time. They joke about being a and they joke
about not being a and they accuse other people being Okay, so
just so you know, I got >> Wait, are you saying that it's
not that big a deal to call somebody then? What is this argument?
One, super weird for a community to do that. That's really not
that's super weird. But two
>> this from >> I am a >> you see they joke
about knocking
>> which is which is a joke. Okay, just so you know people
do this in TG chat all the time. They joke about being a
>> No, they joke about which is weird. Okay, but
but doesn't that made it like doesn't that make it not bad what
he said and there's no reason to swat him over it or to to call
for him to be doxed or swatted? Am I Am I crazy? Like there's
no reason to say you're so happy that his family's getting harassed
over being called a if that's a joke they throw around all the
time. >> They joke about not being a and they accuse other
people being better. Okay, so just so you know, I got this from
the culture of DG chat. So you can't just say, "Yeah, I got I
got like this stupid edgy joke, right? From the culture of DG
chat. I use it." And then now you hate the same joke that I got.
>> Dude, this is this is actually insane. Hold on. They
joke both ways. I got it. So they This is actually insane, right?
that she's basically saying, "Oh, I used this joke that's like
a community joke and you didn't like that." So, you said it back
and then I crashed out and said, "I'm happy your wife got doxed
and harassed and I'm happy your kids might get doxed and swatted
or whatever the she said. I don't care if your kids get doxed
or swatted." Whatever the she said, right? That's totally insane.
That's completely insane
that she just gave up any reason she had to actually say that
to Dan. anything where she's like, "Oh, well, you know, he said
the worst thing on the internet to me." You literally just said
it's like a part of the culture there, which is again for the
rest of us, we're like, "Oh, that's super weird. We ain't never
heard of that."
But apparently normal for you guys. I'm going to put the chat
back on the screen here. The kick chat >> the inspiration
from the culture. You don't know. It's so stupid because they
do this all the time as well. It's just >> but okay.
>> You saw that, right? that man. I'm
>> No, but like but you understand that her reason for
saying the about Dan's family was because he had her but then
she just said that it's totally normal to people is a joke in
that community.
I I'm curious what outside of or I mean Dan really thinks she
is a but what in that community in text chat would let you know
that they're they don't really think you're a pig
>> and and I've seen tons of int chat where it's like just
randomly like name xn name great y name like I see that all the
time the humor is just kind of like that it's a [__]
okay like what do you want to say >> that is yeah that's
basically this and I was like it happens all the time I have
this somewhere I don't give a [__] it's just kind
of weirdbody
who gives a let's just continue there for encouraging conduct
So Mutin, it seems like Mutin is trying to just move on. Okay.
All right. Good for you, Mutin. Okay. For that position. Okay.
I think that's it would be even if I was like, you know, maybe
someone should call protective services. It seems like each is
getting abused. I saw a video of her getting slammed into the
wall. Like that's not illegal for me to do that. It's [__]
up because I've been getting on the floor.
Okay. That like it seems like it just
like if you if you have a reasonable belief that um someone's
kid like >> did am I crazy or did we skip past the the
clips of food shops?
>> Keep in mind, okay, Dan is basically enabling
Dan is becoming the agent of JTO. Okay. His his transformation
into the agent for the anti-fans is >> what I think it's
very funny. No, no, no. Hold on. No. I listen.
>> No, no, no, no, no, no.
If only
if only the plan
could be discovered so
We operate in much deeper ways than you could possibly imagine.
that we would deploy Dan in such a transparent fashion.
Never. Never. Never. We would never do such a thing.
Dan operates on his own. What does Dan
believe his motivations are? What are his motivations? Well,
that's difficult to say. Let's just say if if our hand was involved,
if we were involved here at all,
you wouldn't suspect a thing.
You would not suspect a thing.
Okay. I I'm sorry.
I I'll I'm going to keep leading into it a little bit, but we'll
see a little bit there. Sure. If it's if it's a good faith observation,
sure. Obviously. Yeah. Yeah. So, we can disagree with that, but
the nature of the message and whether it's Red matters to me.
I do say I want to take a step back, right? Like this is all
stuff that I think about the ethics of people's conduct online
and that for example stuff and all this matters. That's kind
of true here. >> Sure. That's I want to clear about whose
conduct say I hate these like fetch fetch quest.
I've asked this a few times and you never answer. Are you afraid
>> and that was the motivation?
>> Whoops. I had skipped a little bit past where food shops
actually
concern >> told me that you guys were talking calling me
a what's going on here.
>> Okay. You have clips out of there saying that you're
a pedophile. What are we supposed to think? I asked you in DG
chat once. I said I asked you in DG.
>> Okay. I'm sorry. Did we miss this yesterday? Oh, this
is a little while ago. Oh no.
Oh, I hate to inject it, but it's so funny.
Oh, no. No. Twitter. Buying a plushy of a does not mean you romanti
romanticize, glamorize, or fetishize.
Now, this person says the plushy. Now, that's not really all
that funny
if you don't look any deeper, but it is a little funny. It is
just a little funny when you zoom all the way up and you see
that it is uh
this person who's actually posting
I can't make it up. Can't make it up. Can't make it up. Can't
make it up. Sorry. That's Listen, I'm not going to I'm not going
to weaponize that as much as I should. I should, but I'm not
going to. Okay, G chat. I said, "Are you a >> you type
dot dot dot."
>> and that was it. So, why not just answer why just answer
the question? I don't know who you are, so I'm obviously trying
to learn if you're Also, Also, can I just say it's so weird.
Like, it's >> Hold on. Hold on. Oh, I
I had no I just want to point out I had no hand in making this
Twitter post. We had no We had nothing to do with this. We We
don't communicate with these people. We There's nothing no patterns,
no connections, nothing.
Okay. Everything's fine. Everything's fine. [__]
weird that
What did I just get shot by? Hello? Was that a player? Anyway,
whatever. Doesn't matter. Like again, it's just kind of weird
that like is this a question you should ask people? Like, can
you just imagine me going up to someone I barely
>> Again, it's so funny that she's like, "Oh, you Why would
you ask this to somebody randomly? Appropo of nothing." Well,
no. They've seen a bunch of clips of you doing this.
>> I think you're Can you please confirm to me whether
or not you're
>> Oh, I don't get it. Um, food shop's entire like thing
to try to go after Dan here is saying that he's a Jtock ally.
Um, that's how Destiny argued against Pisco the other day. Seems
like just webbing to me and my plan. Okay. my plan to destroy
everything adjacent to Destiny. That seems to be like the best
argument these people can make against anything nowadays. Okay.
And so we're just laughing and pointing out that everything that
happens is part of the plan. It's all part of the plan. The equation
was written long ago.
We're just watching it unfold. >> Why do I owe you this
answer? What?
>> or not? I've asked this a few times and you never answer.
Are you a yes or no? Like this is such a weird like such a weird
thing to Hey, hey, J. Jock. Why do you let this person like a
log you and you like don't respond to their content?
>> Oh, you know, you'll see >> to demand someone.
It's just so weird. Like, what the [__] >> Okay,
triple ass. I won't call you pedal anymore. How hard is that?
>> Uh, I mean, you can continue to call me pedal if you
want. Like, I don't like what do you want? I need to call. I
probably shouldn't have said this, but like I was in the middle
of some Yo. Hey yo, what's up? you. Oh, you you okay I you need
to learn that there are substantive I don't want to say like
legitimate but at least substantive
>> Oh, this guy just got this guy just got annoyed the
same way I did. Oh my goodness. No [__] way. Hey,
you're pretending that this is just like a totally random thing
that brought up for no reason. I wonder where Chaa may have been
made aware of these clips. I wonder where that could have happened.
might be based on like the what you said before in the past.
>> When people ask you in TG chat, they're not asking that.
They're not asking like as a joke and they don't want you to
joke. You should probably go on like a campaign where you where
you just say no every single time. Like it's not it's when people
when people like when people see those those statements and these
G chat, they're you're just kind of feeling the fire where people
are that's what people expect from you. Now people like think
that you're some >> Sure. Okay. Yeah. Sure. I understand
what you're talking about. But the problem here is that um number
one, I have gone on a campaign saying no and no and no and no
before. Okay. It's just never worked. Like there's something
like because because if I say no, they'll think I'm lying, right?
You're getting more more attention now. Now that you're in DG,
you're becoming a more popular >> uh orbiter. You're becoming
a more prominent figure now that before in the past you were
no [__] Now you're getting actual people. And now
ever since you've been in DG, you you kind of just [__]
you kind of just play around the fact. You kind of like beat
around the bush. You're like, "Oh, whatever. I don't give a fuck."
You should kill a [__] Like Mr. Putin when he says,
>> "Okay, that is the most insane respon."
No, I don't care if you call me a pedophile. No, you should.
No, you should care. No, no, you should. You should care. Actually,
>> when when Mr. Mutton is asking whether or not you should
be a The reason he's asking is because he wants to know whether
or not he should uh he should like correspond with you, whe he
should affiliate with you. That's like the whole reason he's
asking because he doesn't want to affiliate with somebody who
he thinks might >> I mean, hold on. You got to let me respond.
If if he doesn't want to affiliate, he doesn't have to affiliate.
Okay, that's number one. Number two, um you said, hold on, let
me respond. Number two, um you said, "Yeah, why don't you just
respond?" No, no, no, no, in DG chat. Okay, typically people
who are asking that question in DG chat specifically, they're
not actually looking for a genuine answer or >> I know
they're not looking. >> No, let me answer. I have to explain
myself wrong every single time. >> Okay, go ahead. I'm
sure >> I have to be okay. Like, do you notice how it's
kind of weird that you're like,
>> isn't it kind of weird how you guys like don't like
Have you noticed like that that total
that total disgusting
prejudice you have against?" Isn't that [__] up,
isn't it? >> You have to be strong against the people who
are trying to
call me a PDF. Like a bunch of people calling me a PDF.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Against those people. Yeah. Yeah. Those
are the people you should be strong against. Yeah, 100%. Do >> I
have to be strong against that, bro? Like, you're telling me
to fight a battle that is essentially like like so difficult
to fight, it's just impossible, right? You're telling me to keep
on like um refuting my allegation again again? Like I would never
ask Steven to refute his allegation again and again. Like even
if he debunks his own allegations, even if he spends time debunking
that, the people who are going to ask in the future, even 5 years
from now, are 100% like are 100% still going to be putting that
on him. But he shouldn't feel the obligation to respond like
every single time, right? And this is the part that I feel like
people don't understand about
>> the obvious answer here, just in case anyone was wondering
what the real answer is. The real answer is you make a video
on it one time addressing it like Bosch did. Even with whatever
lies you're going to go with, you tell the story that you're
going to tell forever after that point. Okay? You cannot change
things after that. You make one video responding and then anytime
somebody asks, you say, "I have a video on this. You can go watch
that. I'm not I'm not handling this right now. I don't talk about
this. It's false. Here's the video explaining why. Go watch it
there. Just in case anyone was curious, that is the that is how
you actually handle this >> content is that like even if
you disprove the allegations a single time, it's going to come
back again and again. The reason why I said this was like lolliggate
version 4 is because it literally is like the fourth time that
I have to like respond to the same thing over and over again,
right? And obviously like I'm I'm a lot more calmer this time,
but it's just like it just makes no sense, you know? That's it.
>> Okay, there's two things. one when you when so those
people who are they're obviously trying to bait you but when
you see that when you when you give into that you're giving them
exactly what they want you're giving them more ammunition for
them to call you a you DG chat you want to build a bigger brand
in DG chat you probably you probably should want to build a bigger
audience in DG chat and become like at least a more likable figure
there you need to not give you need to at least say no every
single time you can't just say oh well like whatever >> are
you okay okay are are you I mean Like I I think you have a point
there as in like okay maybe you should put that out there but
I'm just saying like I I'm pretty sure I have addressed this
like multiple times on my channel even now right and I don't
think anybody is like actually
>> the problem food shops has is that there is no way to
address this categorically right that she has lied so much about
it in the past that now trying to address it she has to lie and
change the story moving forward that there is no way to address
this and make it makes sense. It's just all lies the whole way
down. She cannot ever reconcile something that works for people
in the present with the things she said in the past.
They just
>> aren't watching people that's fine. That's fine. That's
fine.
No, no, no. I understand. Okay. But here's the thing. Do you
believe in tip for tat? Like do you believe in like trying to
cater to people and whatever like that? Like what what is your
opinion on that? Because if you if you believe in that >> principle
thing, this is this is Oh no would be like, "Oh, hey, this person
calls me. I'm going to call him pedophile back." You're you're
saying these people are calling you a pedophile and then you're
just saying, "Oh, it's a meme. [__] yeah, I am."
And then like, "I don't give a [__] I watch whatever."
>> Wait, hold on. When was the last time I said, "Yeah,
I was." When did I say >> Well, no. I'm so
the dot. When somebody asks if you're a pet and you say dot dot
dot, that's what everyone hears. That's that that's the translation.
That's the translation from
vernacular. Okay. Somebody asks you if you're a pedop and you
say dot dot dot and don't respond further. That's yeah to everybody.
That's >> I remember at least within the last week you
said that you look at that. I know you have. >> Hey, is
that a confession to me saying that I'm a PDF? Hello.
>> I It's not
I feel bad for this guy. Not because I actually feel bad for
it's just like he's giving good advice. He's giving precisely
good advice. Hey, you should stop talking about all of this stuff.
Hey, have you thought about not talking about your sex attracted
to? Have you thought about just not doing that at all as content?
Like, don't make your degeneracy a part of your stream. You have
you thought about that? That could be a good idea. No. No. Food
shops, double down on being a total degenerate. Double down on
the double down on not denying your opinion. Double down on >> It's
not in DGA. They're going to they're going to they're going to
call you a just for >> Okay. So, why' you frame it like
that? Because the problem that I have here is that you're trying
to frame me like, "Oh, why' you like if I was going into GG chat
and I was genuinely going like, "Hey guys, I'm a PDF or whatever."
Then yeah, like I probably deserve to be like that because it's
like, why would you blame me for something like that, right?
This chaa guy is trying to be nice. So when he comes in and says
there's some there's some substance to this or he I think he
said I don't even want to say substance. He's trying to be kind
here, right? He's trying not to blow her up, but basically like
I think what he's going to say is no, no, no. There are actual
things that happen that you said that are really bad. >> But
the problem is that people are >> the way that you work
around it. When I'm sorry when I'm I don't really mean to say
that you're exasperating. You're like saying you're like celebrating
that you're you're a PDF. You're not. >> Yeah. I don't
like that framing. Like that's just straight. You're giving you're
you're creating a you're creating this like kind of like view
where everybody every time that they look at you and every time
that everybody asks they well now oh this person didn't
>> uh like they didn't object to being a oh that must mean
that they are if if they're like the what mutton says is when
you were in chat with him and when he's asking you give them
dot dot dots you give them blank answers you just ignore them
you do that and then in chat you say that oh yeah I have like
a you do all that you're going to get you're going to get
>> Ruben Ruben there's no time like the present to buy
kicks and use kicks for donations. Okay. No time like the present
Ruben Rubin to make the transition to >> these [__]
responses where people are going to say that you're and people
>> I think >> Oh, I'll even I'll go Hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. Right now in the middle of this stream, Ruben Rubin,
I will interrupt myself to go over to my botrix and switch my
kick alert to go down to $3 for you. Okay, give me a second.
I'll have to go and make sure that it works for $3 donations.
Although I think Oh, I do have $3. I think that's my bad. It
it's $5 minimum to get the TTS.
>> I think that if people ask me in
whether or not I'm a PDF, that's ridiculous. That's a ridiculous
standard to set in my opinion. Like if you ask if I ask >> you
have to do that,
>> is this a conversation? Hello. Is this mic working?
Like >> this guy doesn't want to say, "Hey, you said some
crazy [__] that you have." >> I'm trying to
have a conversation here. Okay. Like again,
in my opinion, I'm trying to provide my justification. Okay?
If in public, if in public, why is it why is it considered like
weird when you are the one who is in the wrong for giving a answer
or or not giving an answer when the other person is the one who
is asking or trying to imply that you are a PDF, right? Like
like I would never go up to a stranger or go up to someone I
don't know and go like, "Hey, I think that you're a PDF. Can
you prove that you're not a PDF or something?" Like what the
am I supposed to like like and the other person says no. Like
I don't think the obligation should be on them to say no because
in my opinion if you say that to me in public that's a bad faith
question because if you actually did care about like whether
or not I was actually a PDF or not, you would DM me in private
and people have DM me in private before and I've explained whether
or not like like my entire history, right? If PDF more like PDM2F,
am I right?
PDM M2F. I got it. Like PDF as in like they're trans. I
Yes. Thank you so much, Ruben. Ruben, it's actually funnier than
my laugh. I gave a sarcastic laugh. >> Mr. Mutin really
cared. He would DM me in private. But let's just be honest. The
reason why he did that in DG chat is because he doesn't give
a right. >> You're That's 100% true.
>> He wants cover. Actually, that's what these people all
want. They don't care if you're actually food shops, but you
can't be credibly accused of being a and be around them without
them checking. Right. That's why Mr. Putin, when you say, "No,
I'm not a" He just goes, "Oh, cool. Now I don't have to ask again."
It's on tape. I asked you. Right. Right. That's all he wants.
He doesn't care if she's a He doesn't give a
Dan doesn't care if she's a Destiny certainly doesn't care if
she's a They don't give a Give them plausible deniability and
they'll just move forward. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. You're 19, right?
>> True. But that's that doesn't make that you have to
say right now. You're looking at yourself as though you're a
person on the street. You're not a person on the street. you're
a celebrity like you're a micro celebrity but you're a public
figure. So when people go up to you and they ask you hey are
you a and then you work around it as a public figure that means
that now people are going to look at what your statement or not
statement is to that and now that's how they're going to perceive
you. >> Okay. I I mean we might just have to agree to disagree
because like in my opinion I Okay. What what do you propose from
now on to do? Okay. What what would your be actionable plan in
your opinion? Okay. when you are in DGG and when everybody anybody
asks because those people definitely don't watch your content
they definitely don't watch the where you deny being >> I
no hold on hold on I will say >> they don't they don't
100% I'm not talking about that I'm not talking about that I'm
not talking
>> it's literally just the Breaking BAD SCENE NO FOOD SHOPS
NO SAY YOU'RE A PEDOPHILE DON'T IGNORE THE ACCUSATIONS FOOD SHOPS
NO it's a bunch of people coming along and doing that and she's
just like whatever Do not do not. >> Okay. I don't like
how you're cutting me off every single time I'm about to say
something like >> you're coping. >> You're coping.
>> What in my opinion? What do I have to
>> All she has to do No, there's one more thing. Killinger,
she now needs to deny being a publicly and like kind of answer
these allegations in some way they could defend, right? And then
never give other people. All Mr. Putin wants, all Dan wants is
plausible deniability. So they can go, "No, I didn't really know
that she was like this. No, I didn't really know what I didn't
know anything about this. I don't know. No, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no. Right. That's all they want. They just want plausible
deniability, but she won't give it to you. >> And do you
think that every single time somebody brings that up to me, I
have to say no to every single one of them? Every single time.
>> No, not every single one of them. But if you if there's
a if there's somebody if you're in chat and you're responding
to somebody in chat about that, you have to say no. That's like
kind of the obligation that you have at that point. So like,
let's say you're in DG chat. If you're in DG chat, you're chatting
and chatting and chatting and somebody asks you that, you can
do one of two things. You either ignore them or if you respond,
you have to say, "Hold on. No, no, no. I don't I don't like this
representation
because you don't have the large." >> I don't like this
representation. I don't No, no, no. I don't like what you're
saying. The reason why I don't like what you're saying is because
you're assuming that everybody in there is is talking in good
faith. You're assuming that everybody in there is not trolling.
You're assuming No, whenever
>> Gummy verse donated $5 testing.
>> There you go. Gummy verse. I don't know what's going
on with Rub Ruben, but working for Gummy Verse. Thank you very
much for the five. Oh my god. >> I'm trolling when I'm
in there. >> Okay. Is Is this just going to be a yap session?
Like you can just preach to the choir. You can just start up
your own >> You're talking over me. It's not like >> I
think we are I think we are five away. One sub or $5 away from
another hour. >> Talking over you. You're talking over
me, too. It's not like this is that's just how it how it works.
>> Yeah, but you're asking really spicy questions and I
think that it requires like long explanations and detailed like
and not like vague responses and quick quips. You know what I
mean? So, um, in my opinion,
>> I have literally heard JTO use this argument about why
Destiny should address his claims.
>> Um, yeah, I like the argument like, hey, just prevents
people from being able to use this um in a way that convinces
your fans. Yeah, exactly. >> Madison, thank you for the
gifted sub. We'll add the hour to the stream. Thank you so much,
>> I don't I didn't even to be honest, >> I might
have missed exactly what his argument was. Private Huff, thank
you for the gifted sub as well. Five subs away from another hour,
guys. I'll do cheap hours for a little bit here. >> If
people are if people are like having a conversation, if they're
having a conversation with me, right, and then eventually the
PDF question comes up, then yeah, of course I'm going to be like,
"No, I'm not an actual PDF. I know these allegations came up,
but like I'm not actually whatever, right?" But like when
90% of the people who are asking them with no prior conversation
before that point
are asking that question why should I respond to that because
I don't actually have conversations in DGG chat right it's really
hard to have convers I don't even have any conversations in DG
chat so when people are asking me it is straight out of nowhere
there is no prior goodwill that is established why should I assume
they're asking in good faith right because if I just say no what
will They'll just say,
>> "So, this is particularly stupid when the exact hypothetical
we're doing is Mr. Moot. You think Mr. Moon wants to [__]
you over? Is Mr. Mutton's just a random person who you think
is like a troll?
Shouldn't you?" Like, this doesn't even make sense. She doesn't
think through the things she says ever. He never uses her brain
to like observe the world and then think about what she should
say. She just rattles off whatever words come to the the tiny
tiny like cache space that's in her brain. Okay. She's got like
8 kilobytes up there and she just rattles out whatever words
she can. No context. >> Yeah. Copium. Copium. You're crying.
You're crying. >> Okay. Well, you have Okay. So, the problem
is you have to build No. No. You have to build that that goodwill
and good trust. You have to build it with with Destiny's audience
if you want to be Destiny's orbiter. You have to build it. If
you if so, if you go into chat and somebody asks you, you're
probably just going to have to say no. You're just going to have
to bite the bullet and just say no because you have a backlog
of kind of edge spicy clips, edgy clips. So, when you go into
it, you're going to have to say no. That's just kind of how it
works. >> I mean, if you say so, but I guess I just don't
really put that much of a priority on like >> uh this is
wrong. As somebody who actually Okay, as somebody who actually
built up a community within that community, this is wrong. Okay,
that's how you build something that can't possibly last. Now,
as much as my community is probably about eh 60% 70% of the size
it was now for 433 viewers, I mean about 500 600 viewers by myself.
That that would have been an absolute max out back when I was
with Destiny, right? When I was like in that community. Um if
I had big panels with a lot of people, I get more viewers, but
the same would go for now. I really think people
just don't understand. You don't want to build something that
is just around that community. You don't want to just in like
indoctrinate
yourself. You don't want to be like only seeking their approval.
You just want to make good stuff. You just make good content.
That's your that should be your only focus. You just consistently
produce good content and even the people who hate you will start
watching.
That should be the only focus. That is the only focus. Ingratiate
was the word I was looking for. Yes. Ingratiate yourself. Your
focus is ingratiating yourself. You're going to warp your takes
to get their approval. And of course, everybody there, by the
way, this Chaa guy, I think, is a mod or something, right? Or
he's like a direct, he's a conductor or something. Like, they
want you to do that. They want you to operate in a way where
you are to totally beholden to that community in every way. That's
what they want. That's not what you should want because then
you have to deal with Dan treating you like go cattle like this.
Okay? This advice doesn't apply to boring people, by the way.
They're better off leeching. Well, I mean, I'm just explaining
if you want to do your own thing, this is what you should do.
>> Getting the goodwill of DJ. Like, in my opinion, you
know, I don't know. Like, that's just not really a big priority
of mine. Like, in my opinion, if all like if if 90% of DJ chat
believes that I'm a PDF or whatever, like number one, it it's
really hard to have a conversation with each of them or or try
to disprove each of them. Like, for example, let's just say I
respond. >> Yeah, sure. Let's just say >> Yeah. Let's
just say I respond to them once. Okay. Let's just say I say no
once. Okay. So, somebody says, "Are you a PDF?" Okay, just very
simply, "Are you a PDF?" And I >> Come on, JCO. Don't you
miss your chat filling up with Destiny is live right now every
stream? Well, that didn't happen too much once we built like
the community here, but
I Yeah, it was like
it was very frustrating, right? Like having to run all of your
around that or it felt
but again, I just tried to make things I think it it was pretty
easy once you could just make things about the content. Yeah.
But honestly, I doubt without that community. I will say without
that community, without being a part of that, I would never have
made it, right? I when I first started, I think I'm like passively
entertaining now. Like I'm a good enough streamer that I think
I understand why people watch. Okay? I don't think I'm like a
million viewer streamer obviously, but like I'm a good enough
streamer. I can go through information. I have like a couple
talents. But when I first started, I was I was dog. So I, you
know, I grew because of that.
I think I grew away from it intentionally and food shops is just
like growing into it, just making it.
>> I said no. Okay. And let's just say um 30 minutes later,
okay, while I'm trying to chat in there or whatever, somebody
else um asks again because they weren't there before. They weren't
there when that thing was being answered. So, they ask, "Are
you a PDF?" And I said, and I say, "No." Like, do do you see
what's going on? Is that it keeps on happening and it's not going
to stop people. >> You don't need to respond to every single
claim like that. you can ignore them. But when you when you are
in chat and somebody asks you, you have kind of an obligation
to either ignore it or to say no and outright say like, "Hey,
I'm not going to respond to this. I've said no before. I've had
a longer explanation on my channel if like if they try to get
more in depth to it." Say that, but you shouldn't you shouldn't
be just baiting these like kind of meme response because it is
it is a trolly chat, but you can't just keep going like, "Okay,
hold on. What What do you think about Steven um playing uh the
Mr. girl I'm a PDF song um in the intros before stream starts
whenever he's about to address his allegations or before um even
if he doesn't address his allegations. What do you think about
that? Or um uh Steven
>> uh gets even more concerning when he has real allegations,
but he doesn't have the allegations you have. Like here's the
thing with with Destiny. He's got allegations of being attracted
to like
uh girls who are in puberty or postpuberty, right? And that's
basically what he's described. You have described attraction
to girls that are
You have done this. You're the person who's described what's
your like ideal age. Hold on a second. Let me go let me go check
and see what's going on here. Okay,
one second. One sec. One second.
Here's the one. Here's the one I'm looking for.
>> I'm only into the most feminine of the most feminine.
>> That's what I'm saying. >> I need to I need to
have a little girl to wrap myself around. >> Oh, like you're
like big spoon is what you're saying.
Oh, I get you. >> I need to have like a 12-year-old. >> What?
And like it's just multiple clips over time where it's not it's
not describing like a one-off joke where she also describes being
attracted to like adult women, normal looking women, right? It's
it's not like describing other women she's attracted to. It is
a consistent pattern of describing features, secondary characteristics
that she is attracted to. It is a persistent pattern over time.
So, if Destiny had done that and then he had the acquisition
and then he played the song, we'd all go, "Yeah, well, I mean,
that is about on par for the course." Like like, "Okay, yeah,
he's he is he is." >> The power dynamic clip is worse.
Well, we need to keep doing the stream for a little bit. >> When
he's reciting Mr. Girl lyrics about being a BDS like randomly
on stream
huge difference is because Destiny has already boughten the Goodwill
with his own community. You're trying to move into another community
with where you have to buy that Goodwill. So he doesn't need
to cuz it's already his community. He already he already knows
that the people in the outside communities are going to what
they're going to think of him what they're going to think of
him but he doesn't give a so he's b his own community is just
a meme he can meme with his own community because he already
he's already made the goodwill with it. You are trying to move
in >> the goodwill not being that he's definitely not a
the goodwill being that they just love him no matter what >> community
you're trying to build a broad a broader audience now. You have
to you're going to have to you're going to have to be more consiliatory.
you're going to have to say, "Hey, yeah, I'm not a You can't
just play those games."
>> I I I I don't know if I agree with you. Just mainly
because if he has goodwill with his own community, that's fine.
And I agree with you. Like his own
>> purple monkey
dishwasher.
Okay. Thank you very much, Bruce Willis. Appreciate the five.
>> Community won't turn against because they're like a
bunch of like actual genuine fans and whatever, right? But the
problem is that what what is also going on is that other people
are watching Destiny streams who are looking to see the context
of his drama, right? People who are outside the DG community.
Can I use your argument as well when it applies to the broader
community that he's trying to outreach for for >> I don't
know. I I would have to think about that. I would say specific
I think it's very specific for you because you are trying to
trying to move into another community. You're trying to become
more popular there. You're trying to build your audience there.
If if not, then why are you this Destiny?
>> Oh, hold on. Hello.
>> Still, thank you for the gifted sub. Appreciate it,
dude.
>> Wait, wait. Do you think I'm only doing the Destiny
orbiting stuff just to >> No, I'm saying I'm saying that
you are. Therefore, you're trying to build a bigger audience
there. If you I mean, you are doing that. >> I'm not I
mean, if you are if you if you want to [__] if you
don't give a [__] about Destiny or Destiny's audience
or anything like that, that's fine. But then
you would talk
That would be like you wouldn't do any of that. You would just
do your own stream and then you wouldn't you wouldn't even go
into Destiny's voice channel and do any of that. You would just
you just do that. You want to build a a bigger audience there
just as like a it just I think that's just a human thing is you
want to build your audience. It's like that's like that's just
a creator. I don't know. I don't I I Okay, there's like multiple
reasons why I disagree with you there, but like one of the reason
I disagree with you there is like what how much more of an audience
I can obtain do you think I can get from disproving allegations
in DG Chow of all places, right? The way that you're trying to
frame it is like, oh, it's a pecking order kind of thing where
it's like a a giant kingdom that you're supposed to like like
ascertain or whatever. No, it's a
chat where people
each other all the time and you assume you should assume that
99% of the things people say in there are complete trolls, right?
You're telling me to take 99% troll chat seriously. It's a crazy
demand to try to ascend in like the done pile of like of DG chat
like like I don't know why that is the standard that has put
on me when the reason why I defended Destiny in the first place
isn't because I want to >> yeah you don't have to don't
appeal the DG chatters orbit even though in my opinion it is
a benefit to me right like I won't deny it's a benefit but at
the same time I've I've done it before Destiny even noticed me
because in my opinion it's It's a worthwhile battle because I
believe in the things I'm talking about, right? >> Okay,
that's fine. But like you're >> for Yeah. I'm just saying
for you to assume that weird. >> I don't want you're you
there's an audience there. You're kind of expanding into that
audience and you have the opportunity to make a bigger expansion
into Destiny's orbit into Destiny's audience and at least buy
goodwill so that you can appear on Destiny's stream so he can
talk to him more so that he can be on your stream and he can
talk to you more. You can do that. You can do that if you if
you if you're if you're more hard.
>> Odds that Destiny has blocked her too. Pretty low. I
think I'm hearing tell that uh Dan completely conceded. He completely
conceded to her. I believe Dan has
thrown in the the towel. Actually raised a white flag
against all odds.
Food shops has prevailed. Really shouldn't have been against
all odds, right? Like Dan is
in the DGG community. That isn't a popular position, right? So,
realistically, we probably should have expected something like
this >> against the uh against these claims. When you go
into Destiny's chat, you're saying, "Oh, they're just jacking
each other." That's because people in DG chat when they're trolling
with each other, there's actually no backing to that. When they
when when I think what's his name? There's somebody in chat.
>> What if what
he he calls me a for literally no
>> You see, we call each other a or something. that's,
you know, there's no backing substance to that to anyone calling
me a So, it's like a joke. But with you, there's like a lot of
backing substance to the idea that you're a
So, when you when people say it to you, it's like up and and
and you need to answer it. Otherwise, you know, you're leaning
into it. It's you're leaning into it when you already have all
these allegations. You've made these statements. It's [__]
up, man. >> Come on. That's not okay. Yeah, that's obviously
not okay. Yeah. >> No, I think he does it just because
he hates me and he doesn't like me. No, people call you PDF.
That's obviously not Wait, hold on. Why the [__]
Wait, hold on. I'm so confused. Why would I want to ascend in
a chat where people call you PDF because they hate you? That
makes no sense. Like, why do I
You're No, no, no. You're automatically assuming you're The problem
is that you're automatically assuming that I want to ascend in
a place like that. I What if my goal was never to ascend into
DGad? That's That was never my go. Why would I ascend in a place
like that? It
>> Well, you always have to be subservient to destiny.
If you're not subservient to destiny, that is like the greatest
crime in those parts, right?
That's that's really what it is. >> I've always said again
and again on my own stream that I dislike DJ. I've always hated
DJ. >> You're building your audience there. You're building
your audience in Destiny's. You're building it there. It's never
been my primary goal. You stop. Stop. That's never been my primary
I I see it. No, no, no, no. If I if I >> Do you want to
stagnate here at like what 100 viewers or whatever for like forever?
No. You want to build more viewers? You want to get build a bigger
audience
audience?
>> Wasn't this person just talking about how they really
wanted my whole career to die and they Yeah, they were watching.
They were so glad that my numbers would go down, wanted my career
to die.
That was that was one I heard. That's um
>> That's She has more than aundred viewers. Come on. There's
no way it's
like that's already the problem with what you're saying is that
there's a growth cap as well. Like if I only try to appeal to
DG, why why don't I appeal to why don't I appeal to communities
outside of DG as well? Because that's what I've been trying to
do this entire time because I know that if I cover um JTOK every
single day, I know that a bunch of DJers will just flock and
watch my streams. But the reason why I don't do that every single
day is because um there's this trap that content creators constantly
fall into where they pigeon hole themselves into covering one
type of content and they're trapped within this one community,
right? Why would I try to make my way towards um do this >> Did
I just get mentioned there? I sorry >> because I know that
if I cover um JTO every single day, I know that a bunch of DJers
will just flock and watch my streams. But the reason why I don't
do that every single day is because um there's this trap.
>> You don't follow politics enough to comment on any of
my political >> Creators constantly fall into where they
pigeon hole themselves into covering one type of content and
they're trapped within this one community, right? Why would I
try to make my way towards pigeon holding holding myself even
more when I'm actually trying to get out of the algorithm in
terms of that thing, right? It makes no sense to me. That's counterintuitive
to my goals. her audience in multiple different ways and you
can >> she used to be on Destiny's subreddit used to DM
Destiny before she streamed Eid why she would deny wanting his
attention now.
>> Uh that's a good Yeah, that's a good point and a good
Yeah, hold on one second. I get it. I get it. I get it. I get
it. I get it. Hold on. Hold on. I am
pulling these DMs right now. Why can I What? Hello. Thank you.
Yes.
Can I move this like this? There we go. Okay. So, these are what
from 2022. Guys, I I don't really want to be here forever. I
want to come on stream with my voice. Can I do so? It'll be fun.
What does that mean? I'm bored at the moment. Listening to your
voice in bed while Well, in the background while I'm playing
Dark Souls 3I. Getting my ass kicked by blah blah blah blah blah.
Also, my voice passes as a transgender girl. The most passing
voice ever. I think DG would be happy. Okay, never mind. I just
defeated this thing. One more. One more. One more of her just
one-sidedly DMing Destiny. You know, you weren't my first choice.
Vosch blocked me. And Hunter Applon is a bit too scary. He's
angry too often. So, you're the most chill person. I think I
can beat you in a debate. Good morning, Destiny. I'm going to
go work out now. See you later. Hey, Destiny. Hope you're doing
well today. I'll be canvasing on June 5th. Wish me luck. For
my local assembly member, Destiny, do us like
This is May 24th, May 25th, May 26th, May 28th. By the way, is
this harassment?
Curious. Is this harassment or
how the did you get these DMs? Uh, friends in high places. Yeah.
Anyway, we're continuing. >> You want to build your audience
in your stream in the way that you want to build your stream
and how and how you perceive it. But there's a what I'm trying
to say is that if when you're building your audience in Destiny's
stream, when you're there, you should deny being a because you're
not one. And people when people ask you there, you're saying,
"Oh, well, they're trolling. They're bad faith. It doesn't matter.
Who gives a [__] Like, but it does matter because
now you're you're you're capping what you can do in that in that
space. You're you yourself are capping the audience in that space
just by not doing by just by not denying it. That's all all you
have to do is I'm okay with that. I'm okay with that. >> Like
my my ultimate goal again why why would you question Hold on.
How much do you know about content creation and algorithms and
stuff like that? Like >> I'm I'm sorry. I I am asking you
to I am asking to pull you I I am actually asking you to pull
out your credentials at this point because now you're you're
having an issue with my content creation strategy. So it's like
if you have a issue with my content creation strategy Yeah. I'm
going to ask you to pull out like whatever experience you've
had prior like in terms of content creation because otherwise
like why would I take you seriously, right? >> No, I'm
not I'm not I'm not talking I'm not talking about your content.
I'm just saying that when you >> No, but you are you really
want me to you really want to push in that direction. So yeah,
we have to talk about it. >> No, no, wrong. You're wrong.
I I you can build your stream by your stream. You're missing
the public perception of how you want your if you how you want
to grow is you're capping yourself not just in Destiny's stream
which is where that's the most immediate effect. You're capping
yourself everywhere by not denying it. All right. Destiny doesn't
need to do this anymore because he's already built his stream.
He already built his audience. He probably can't grow any further
than he has based on >> Yeah. I mean, good for Destiny.
Okay. Yeah. Good for Destiny. Good for him. >> Stop here.
Yeah, I I mean I just don't again I don't want to spend all my
time like trying to prove myself to a chat that already hates
me and also is not worth the time. It just makes no sense.
>> you're doing this and Bailey saying like >> I
don't know I don't know how to convince you. It's just like like
what am I supposed to say here?
>> I don't want to deny every single every single instance
of DG chat. I don't want to have to deny every single instance
every single time. >> Imagine being food shops PR manager
>> which is not what I'm saying. But then I go back. >> This
is all going badly, but you have to remember the audience she's
playing to, right? Like realistically,
it might just be that the way to win DG's hearts was to pretend
to be a >> it's not you denying every single time >> or,
you know, if you really want to commit, just be an actual one.
>> It's you playing into it or meaning about it. Like there's
there's definitely a difference between the two where you can't
find some middle ground where you just deny it. Most all like
every time that you're going to acknowledge it, you deny it.
You you're going to have to >> Yeah. because I don't care
all that much about what DG chat thinks of me. >> But you
I mean okay then but then then you're going to have to you're
going to have to struggle with these people. >> I only
I only care
Mr. Mutton and when Dan and Mr. are on stream and they're calling
you a pedophile, you you can't say like, "Oh, I'm not." You can't
get mad at them for thinking you're a pedophile because you're
playing against
I think that's incorrect because I think that users
but yeah, >> okay, can I just finish like
Okay, I I don't know if we can have a conversation like at all.
Like it just you just keep interrupting me. It's just so hard
to speak, I guess. But um and by the way, yes, I do believe that
Chacha is coming in good faith. But then if I think his point
is stupid, then obviously I'm still going to react in such a
way, right? Anyway, the point is is that in my opinion, as content
creators, I think that the burden I think you have a bigger responsibility
when it comes to taking allegations and trying to see like what
the evidence is behind it, right? Like for example, if I was
just a regular chatter and I was just memeing about someone being
being a PDF and then everyone meme along with me as a content
creator, I shouldn't just be taking whatever rumors is being
spread around in DG chat without any evidence, right? And then
and then just like saying it on stream in front of like even
more people and in front and taking it as fact, right? Or trying
to question it as fact or trying to spread rumors around. That's
unreasonable to me because you have a larger level of responsibility
of someone who is a public figure versus someone who is like
a more private figure who is just simply a chatter. Like these
are not the same standard in my opinion. >> I agree. But
you don't think that applies to you as well? >> Yeah, of
course. Of course it applies to me. Of course. Yeah. >> I
I don't know. I >> But I don't disagree with that. Yeah.
That's not where the disagreement is, >> Okay. One other
thing. When you join Destiny uses voice chat, you have to you
have to have something. You You can't just join and then do >> Well,
I mean I mean I mean I got my perms taken away. So uh Yeah. Listen.
Okay. It's all good. Okay. >> Well, next time next time
you have your perms given back to you. >> No, there there's
no next time. Okay. There's no next time. I think I'm good. I
think I'm good. Okay, there's the next >> I'm just going
to join. You should have You should just go
rage. You're actually rage baiting. >> I think people really
misunderstands what I'm doing in this space. I think people really
misunderstands what I'm doing in this space. I'm a true believer
of principles. Okay, I'm a true believer. Everybody else who
who says that, oh yeah, I abide by principles and whatever, they're
they're fake. Okay, they they're >> amazing.
It's like she watches a lot of the content that Queen or I produce,
but then she doesn't understand what any of it means. You know
what I'm saying? Like, it's like she knows the words, but like
an example of not having principles would be like when when Dan
called you a you said that's a joke that gets thrown around DG
all the time and then you said, "Well, I think it's cool that
his kids get doxed and harassed and swatted." I thought I thought
I think that was like probably not indicative of principles wants
to be Mr. Girl. Yeah, it just doesn't have any of the the grounded
um like the grounded moral understanding, right?
Or a hypocrite at one point or another. Okay, I am a true consistency
queen. Okay, because in my opinion the again I have defended
Destiny on this like drama even before he has given me any onstream
attention in any way. Right, that's number one. Number two, right?
I'll probably keep defending Destiny even if I'm kicked out of
orbit. Why? Because I
Not good. Not good
in the things I'm talking about. That's number two, right? And
number three, I want to be that kind of content creator where
it it doesn't matter how I'm looked upon by other communities.
I just want to defend what I think is right. Right? And and you
know what? If that's not to your liking, if you think that's
a bad content strategy, good for you. Okay? That's your opinion.
Right? But but you're you're you're it feels as though you haven't
even asked me how much importance I place on getting the goodwill
of DG chat before assuming automatically that that is like one
of my primary goals. And it's like no, it's not. It's a side
benefit if I take it. It's a side benefit if I take it. >> Building
your building your audience there is a good idea. You there's
a >> So she's done the thing where you only build around
one audience. All of her subscriber base is around that audience.
And then she's going to see exactly why you don't do that. Like
why that is
There's a size audience there for you to pick up where they basically
agree with literally everything you agree with. They like they
like they like the same things you like. They they like it when
you
like they like those things. Your streams could >> surely
that can hold a community together. Surely guys, just hatred
for little old me.
>> Very popular DG. But you're capping
>> I shared this quote with Quimman once a Nasra quote.
Okay. The former leader of Hezbollah. RIP. Not really them, but
RIP. It's like he said he said something that was very cool except
if I'm gonna pretend it's not about okay. He's like, "Thank God
for Israel existing
such that my enemies all collect in one place." Okay. Like that.
And you know, I shared this quote with Queenman. He thought it
was pretty awesome. It's
It's
pretty cool.
All right. And that's how I that's how I feel sometimes >> there
because you choose to >> guys we we DG really loves that
you make this like anti this guy type of content it's really
awesome it's Connor approved in fact >> basically meme
around the fact >> you realize you realize I'm also capping
myself I sh >> you are one so I mean that's just how it
>> hold on you realize I'm also capping myself I [__]
on the anti-fans right I'll explain
when I'm saying no no you said that you agree with the I'm assuming
that you're being >> because if we because if we only assume
Because because if we only assume what is a good choice based
on maximizing viewership and stuff, there could be other things
I could be doing, right? If I was truly shameless,
>> but I choose not to do that. >> I'm not saying
you're being shameless. When I'm saying that you can grow into
destiny space, I'm saying that you would do it by being truthful
to yourself. >> Am I am I going crazy?
I can't tell. >> Did you
deratives? That quote exists in almost every war. Oh, well, I
thought it was I thought it was particularly compelling in this
case because wait, why would they exist in every war? Like the
case of Israel is like really unique. Is it not like a a a people
that's like that decentralized, that like spread out? That's
the point, right? He's talking about from around the globe migrating
back to Israel that like it would be really difficult to go if
they were still a totally decentralized like stateless people.
I don't I don't think that actually makes any sense that it would
be a quote that exists everywhere. And it's in this case it's
like not obviously. Yeah. I don't know. It feels weird there
would be a quote that exists everywhere. Oh, whoops.
>> Oh, we're at the end of the Oh, I think this is dying,
right? We go into the next vault. They're going to keep looking
over this. Okay. All right. I need one more thing here. Sorry,
I'm I'm handling something in the background as well right now.
So, just give me a second. We have one more piece of Okay, we
had all of this stuff and then this cuts out. This is the callin.
Okay, then the stream cuts out. We're going to skip past that
colin. That column was getting kind of boring. This is the next
time >> accusations repeat should be well practiced. But
that burden shouldn't be placed on me. The burden should be placed
on people who are leving PDF allegations with almost no evidence.
Almost no evidence.
Straight up. Okay.
Straight up. It makes no sense. Anyway, like you've had to deal
with these allegations for like two and a half years now. Each
time you explained, if people don't get it, then it's just a
move on next random BS at the wall move. Okay. Sleepy was here
the entire time. Okay. For two and a half years. Okay.
Had to deal with these allegations for for like two and a half
years now. Each time you've explained it, if people don't get
it, they don't it's just a move on next random BS at the wall
move. Lauo, they don't. It's just a move on. It's just a move
on next random BS at the wall move.
Okay. I don't Jesus,
>> Dude, then nothing will top at the very beginning of
this where she's like, "Guys, I do consume." And I'm probably
I'm like I'm pretty certain I'm pretty confident I'm not a I'm
like I'm pretty sure I'm NOT A
NO, NO, you should be 100. That shouldn't be a hedge. Don't hedge
on. I'm not a Don't do that. That's crazy. >> Just a drink.
A martini shaken, not stirred. food shop.
>> Kirby, thank you so much for the $5. Okay, I appreciate
that. Thank you. Um, guys, people need to understand
how long I have dealt with these allegations. How long. And it's
like one of the most popular allegations out there, okay?
How long I have responded to these things over and over and over
again. Okay?
>> Too long. Okay? Too long. >> I am black build.
Okay? I think that if you're not comfortable watching me, then
don't watch me. Okay? If you want to watch me, then watch me
because in my opinion, I would rather be in a situation where
I am comfortable with myself the way I am right now than it is
I don't know trying to do something like just like it makes no
sense. Whatever it is what it is, okay? And you know what? I
I don't think the onus should be put on me. If you want me to
be more popular, I think you should defend me. Okay? I I think
if you truly care about it, you would defend me, okay? Okay.
And show some evidence for it as well. All right. Because I know
who the defenders are, and I don't think any of the people criticizing
me right now are the defenders. Okay? Because I I need I I need
at least some kind of showing that you actually mean what I'm
saying in good faith. Okay? Like Yeah. I don't know. It's just
Yeah. >> Wait, what? Where is this even coming from? Is
it or is it Dan? You guys sound >> Okay. We don't sound
similar. And also, I don't think you get to say that when I've
said it one time and then you immediately go to a stream saying
someone should swat my kids and harass my wife and kids more.
And I think to me that's one of those
cuz I DM' you I DM'd you. I was like, "Hey, you know, like can
we deescalate a little bit?" And then you were like, "No." So
that's where I went to. It wasn't until afterwards. It wasn't
until afterwards I asked to deescalate and you refused to, right?
That's kind of
at the same time. >> Well, I'm trying to show the >> That
was completely like I I I didn't even know what the they were
the overlapping audio is is just completely like how do I join
your biker gang? I want to be a defender. I I don't know, dude.
There there's no official food shops defend squad. Okay. Like
people defend me harder than I defend myself. Okay. At least
>> Oh, they just laughed. They did. >> Oh, got it.
And that's why I criticize his parenting. Okay,
>> That's why I think it's a reasonable Oh, yeah. Magabus,
by the way, cut out the entire Chaa debate. Oh my god, dude.
That's probably going to be a separate like segment on the side
channel. >> Yeah, that whole thing where he said there's
a lot of substance to the pedo. No, get that out of here. Cut
it all. Get it out, editor. Get it all out. It >> It just
interrupts the entire flow. Okay. It just interrupts the entire
flow. I need to get back into the zone.
No. No. It isn't that I dislike you. It's it's not like it it
it kind of interrupts like for people who just want to see my
reaction to anything else like yeah they don't want to sit through
an entire debate to see that escalation. Okay. That's why I think
it's a reasonable escalation. Okay. I hope that your wife gets
harassed more at work. Okay. Holy.
>> Oh. Is Dary still in here? >> He's he's been in
here.
>> [__] chat. >> It gets a little friskier.
Don't worry >> Can't even defend themselves if they would
like to join. Oh, okay. >> I don't There is no defense.
No. I mean No, no, no, no, no. My defense is this. Okay, tit
for tat. That's what you're >> If they'd like to join,
they can come talk. We're >> Dude, there's nothing more
brain damaged. I swear to God, I hear somebody say tit for tat
now. I
I just immediately know that they're completely they have no
thought.
>> Like, okay, if I say something like this, like obviously
I already turn off all the Dan fans. You know what I mean? At
this point, I already turn off all the Dan fans. So, it's like,
yeah, I don't care. I don't want the Dan fans to be my fans.
Actually, >> I think I'm good.
probably in some girlfriend. >> I hear that's been happening.
>> Oh, you needed to appease Dan so then you can get the
Dan fans. No, I I actually don't want the Dan fans. Okay, >> I
think I'm good. >> It's right here.
>> How is she going to answer this clip is the question.
>> Just remember
battle I pick is justified. Okay, just want to >> just
in case anyone wonders if I'm being
>> D is so angry, dude. >> I love you guys. And uh
Chase, hey, be careful. All right. >> Okay. Where's Victory
Ridge?
>> They hate us because they hate us. True.
>> Okay. Here's the part.
>> There you go. Go back.
>> This is like, "All right." >> And why would I
take it back? There's no reason for me.
>> Chops, make sure to sublock this VOD so E can't freload
it for content tomorrow
>> Okay, let's go.
I've done more. >> Make sure to sublock this VOD so AE
can't preload it for content tomorrow morning. Oh, dude.
Are they going to cover me every day, bro? Oh my god. Really?
So cringe. Okay, hold on. How do I How do I Vodlock anyway? >> For
less. >> I mean, I'm sorry. I do think Dan earns the right
to cover this, right?
When when you say that his kids deserve to get doxed and harassed.
I'm sorry. That's like actually true. You think she'd know how
the whole LC cow thing works after Queen farmed her? I guess
so.
She certainly tried to farm my content. I I like actually was
like, "Oh, this is like this person's like farming my content.
What the [__] going on?" And then I watch the stream
and she just like actually sits there brain damaged, not listening,
and like not tangibly responding to anything I say. I'm like,
"Oh, this is as much as like people are watching this, this is
just good for me." Like she's actually just broadcasting my with
no like real tangible response. Anyone who's just clicking into
that. I feel like if they're paying attention, anybody who's
intelligent enough that they could pay attention, they're going,
"Oh, this guy's kind of spitting."
There's actually just helping. >> Holy, bro, he called
him. Yeah, of course I won't feel bad for him anymore. Yeah.
Or for his wife or for his kids. What the Of course not. I hope
they block the VOD. There's no reason for me to block the VOD
either. It's like whatever. I don't know. I don't really care
all that much to be honest. They can like again by the way if
you didn't >> see they're they're even watching this and
they're not responding to this. >> Okay. Because people
are trading like people are treating as if like
people are treating me as if like oh yeah by the way
>> I've never heard of your allegations before. Don't you
think your allegations are insane?
>> Bro, no. The things you said are insane. Not the allegations.
The things you said are insane.
That's the problem. >> Briana Woo, I I kid you not. Okay,
Briana Woo and Counterpoints have farmed me before. They've had
their own podcast and they farmed me for five episodes straight.
If you if this is the first time you're hearing about this,
all right, I'm sorry. Okay.
Yeah. Like like Yeah.
You need you need to you need to appease Briana Woo. Okay. In
order to get the Brianna Woo fans. Surely one more disavow will
do it. >> One more no will do it. >> I don't care.
>> All right. >> Yeah, that's about that was the
main thing. Um >> okay, so they were saying that they tried
to deescalate and you ignored them. Can you explain about that?
>> No, that's not true. They messaged
>> Um they've they've posted them. It was this uh first
off, Mr. Mutton, how many times have you called me in the history
of DG?
>> Okay. How many times? >> What if I give a dude?
That's a dynamic between you and Mr. Mutin. Yeah, I'm going to
call my friends horrendous, right? Like if I'm okay, this is
just an example. Like if I'm calling if I'm if I'm talking to
like Muks in private, okay, I'm just going to be like, "Yeah,
just kidding. I wouldn't say anything like that." But like, yeah,
then but I wouldn't call anybody else like a like why the [__]
would I do that? Like there's no reason for me to do that. Like
if I was talking to Msaki in private, I would say like super,
right? But and they know that it's fine. But like that's me and
a person that >> who cares >> I'm familiar with.
So it's like what's wrong with that? Like there's nothing wrong
with that. But >> I'm conspiring in DMs with like eight
different people right now. We're uh recalculating. Okay. Conspiring
with a lot of different people in a lot of different group chats
right now. Okay. I'm I'm sorry. I'm I'm not really responding
as much as I should be, but it's just going to >> Listen,
it is it just is the way it is.
>> Somebody I'd barely know that, right? [__]
I wasn't paying attention. I lost like 70 viewers while I was
conspiring. God damn it. >> What? Like, this is not a good
point in >> Can we just all agree that this is not a good
point in any way. What >> did I say that I was going to
go and swat and and harass your family? >> Probably zero.
>> Exactly. Um I'm not cool with people around like that,
especially people who go and do it to their >> Well, I
don't know that. You can't assume. I know that. I don't know
why they're assuming. I know the friendship dynamic between Dan
and Mr. Mutin is also applicable to the dynamic between me and
Dan cuz we're not friends.
I'm so
I'm okay. Whatever is >> stream [__] afterwards.
Seriously. And I'll never be. And that's it. So, um when they
said, "Can they deescalate?" I didn't even think I knew that
this clip existed. I will never deescalate now. That is just
It's just We're just >> Okay. Rest of the VOD's just uh
looping. Okay. Okay. Okay. All right. Um, I think we get a quick
update on some of this stuff and then we move on to the next
story, which is going to be the Candace stuff probably.
Sorry, I ended up I was spending too much time conspiring, but
the the conspiring went well. Okay, it's good. Good conspiring,
so don't worry about it.
Worth it, worth it, worth it, worth it, worth it. Oh, hold on.
I'm still I'm still looking into stuff. Okay, I need I need more
stuff. I think I got given There's like a VOD from today, right?
There's a VOD from today. Hold on. Ry send me a vod from today.
Give me a second. Give me a second. I'll throw that up. We'll
watch whatever's going on here. Okay, there's a peace deal between
Dan and and food shops. Now, now here's the thing. If there really
is a peace deal, I actually think that I've never heard of like
a bigger aura debuff than that for Dan. This person like talked
about how it's awesome that his
his wife and kids are getting harassed. His wife got harassed
at work,
dude.
And then she doubled down on it and said, "Yeah, I do get to
say that when he calls me a and then he just backs
and says he won't appar I've heard that he won't call her anymore."
>> Awesome. Okay. All right. Well, let's just get into
it. Okay. >> We'll see. >> So, Dan and I Dan and
I have brokered a peace deal. Okay. And I'm going to give a shout
out to Radiant. Okay. Because it was Radiant that acted as a
liaison between me and Dan. Okay. Dan did not want to speak with
me directly because he didn't want to. All right, fine. So,
essentially, this is the details of the deal. Don't shout out.
I have to. Okay. Because otherwise, it would make no sense. Like,
you're really going to tell me, "Oh, he didn't want to." Okay.
Yeah, whatever. Okay, fine. Lazison, whatever. It doesn't matter.
Everybody already knows already. You're already public about
it. It doesn't matter. So,
here's the conditions of the peace deal. Okay. No, here's the
condition of this. >> What leverage does she have? I I
mean I assumed it was this that Destiny needs a person who will
lie on his behalf to everybody, right? I think that's like what
he needs and he would have told Dan, "No, no, no, no. You can't
go after this person." That's my assumption,
right? That was my assumption from the beginning that like food
shops wouldn't be just thrown away, right? That was the assumption
from the beginning. I thought when they doubled down on going
after Dan's kids and family, I thought like, "Oh, that's probably
too far. I think he has leverage now, but apparently not. Apparently,
she gets to do that and then he kneels.
Very shocking. >> And and I'll I I'll just say real quick
um what it's all about. Okay.
>> Yeah. This is what I think. Yaposaurus. >> Um
don't worry, I'll make it quick. Okay. Jeez. So, basically, uh
I criticized Dan, right? And that has led up to a bunch of um
I guess in the long run, uh I pissed him off um and he pissed
me off, right? Um, but that doesn't mean that we're good. It
just means that we have a mutual understanding. Okay, so we hit
the reset button. All right, we hit the reset button a little
bit. Okay, we're not on good terms. Okay, but the peace deal
is still a thing. All right, however, I will say, all right,
um, basically here's the thing. I don't talk about his family,
his wife, his kids,
and he won't call me a PDF or imply any such thing. Okay? like
like I would imagine like >> Oh, this is such a massive
aura debuff. Oh, no.
Oh, Dan lost so badly.
That's rough, man. Listen, he's getting old. He's getting old.
So, it's maybe a little understandable. >> Calling me a
is also crazy. Okay, so we both agreed to match energy. That's
essentially what it is. Okay, we both agreed to match energy
and because at some point we were escalating attacks on each
other, right? Like basically because he called me PDF, I attacked
his family, right? And I think part of that >> he called
me a PDF, I attacked his
>> Energy is also this. Okay. >> Oh man. >> Uh
I will not retract that wife children statement on stream. >> She
won't even she won't even retract. She still believes. So she
comes out. She says, "Actually, we're not going after each other
before, but I do still believe that his wife deserved the
Dude, come on.
>> Also retracts the PDF stuff on stream, but honestly,
it's not needed. I I'll be honest. It's
>> Oh, hey Dan. I'll only say your wife doesn't deserve
to be doxed and harassed and your kids, you know, dox and
>> If you say I'm not a If you lie to everybody, it's >> not
needed. Okay. Because I want to deescalate tensions. So, it's
not needed. Um, but for people, some people are talking about,
you know, are you going to retract your comments? Are you going
to retract your comments? Well, again, right, we're trying to
match energy here. So, a retraction is going to be met with a
retraction, and escalation is going to met with the escalation.
Okay? It's as simple as that. All right? >> Okay. And >> now
I will say, all right, I trust
this
or I should say food shops should trust this ceasefire
about as much as you'd trust the ceasefire negotiated by any
dual Israeli citizen. Okay,
I' I would be careful. I would be careful. Okay, this is this
is a little I've heard I've heard a hell of this before. A ceasefire,
you say? A ceasefire, you say?
I don't know. I I truly don't believe.
I truly don't believe that Dan would let this go. I actually
don't. I don't think he'd let it go. I think she's saying some
that she got told.
Uh if she thinks it's anything but like total food shop's death
in Dan's mind, I think she's crazy. Especially given she won't
even retract the comment about his wife and kids. I That's pretty
wild.
That's pretty wild.
>> Yeah. Basically, if if the purpose here is to match
energy, Yeah. at first I thought and this is some miscommunication
error I maybe on my part as well is
uh I thought that what Dan was demanding from me is I cannot
commentate on him or criticize him or criticize his character
or his views. Okay. I thought that >> How much subs for
enough time to cover Candace? Um I don't know. We have to go
through a lot of Candace stuff. How much time do we have on the
stream? Because I feel like I definitely phone that in. I can
add I'll add, you know, we'll go back to like an hour 15 or something
because I definitely was not paying attention.
Was just passively absorbing. Okay, I'll go back to an hour 15.
And then if we need more time, we need more
>> That was the case. All right.
>> Destiny needs food shops that much. Yes, he does. Destiny
absolutely needs food shops. I told Dan this when Dan first messaged
me. He was like, "Hey, this person, you should go after them."
The first time that happened,
uh, I told
"No, go solve your own problem, but also you won't be able to
get rid of this person because they're going to lie for Destiny
in a way that you won't. >> Give me my black queen this."
>> Okay. All right, Marma, dude. We're going to get to
it. I promise.
but yeah, she'll she'll like lie and make things up in a way
that Dan won't, right? Not that Dan can't, but Dan like it's
a total hit to your credibility, right? like she won't be she
won't go beyond this arc of just being like the destiny washer.
She can't. It's incapable. So
Dan doesn't want that. Nobody wants that job, right? Why doesn't
he just prop up Zip Zip instead? He has basically no baggage.
That's a good question. I actually don't know. Maybe that's why
Zip Zip's streaming. I actually don't know. We'll see. >> As
our liaison was communicating to me. Okay. I think basically
everybody but food shops would want to actually try to analyze
and be correct.
Like I think even Zip Zip in his heart of hearts wants to be
correct and wants to analyze things. He's just bad at it. But
with food shops, she doesn't she like is incapable of understanding
what correct even is. So she'll just say whatever whatever Destiny
needs her to. She'll say that, right? It's like a big difference.
Like it's it's actually unique to find somebody who wants to
be in this space who has no no like interest in even the veil
like the
uh what would she say like the plausible deniability the
like the mask of correctness like like she she doesn't care at
all. She'll just say whatever Destiny needs her to.
>> At some point we negotiated that I am allowed to criticize
Dan's character. Okay.
Off of that assumption. Off of that assumption, I believe I am
able to criticize his character, but criticizing his character
and criticizing his personality has nothing to do with PDF allegations.
Okay? So, the original conflict of of why it all started in the
first place, right? Like why did it start in the first place?
It's because criticism of his character led up to a PDF jacket,
right? A PDF allegation. Okay? And for me, from my point of view,
okay, that's not just
>> why is it not why is it for food chops criticism of
his character,
right? Just think about this for a second. Why would food shops
say it's just a character critique? Well, that's because
food chops is saying, well, I see like evidence here,
and based on that evidence, I'm saying things that are
But when Dan called me a that was just like a jacketing. No,
Dan's seen the evidence. Dan believes your opinion. That is a
character criticism. He is evaluating your character.
And if you want to disagree with that, well, actually, he's not
even saying what is factoring into his analysis, but I could
easily say like, oh, here's the things you lied about with regards
to your therapy. That is and and you can't make that make sense
now. You've actually made different things up to try to make
it make sense. I don't have to like I don't have to say anything
except I'm gonna like explain this clip. Explain why you said
this about your therapy. Explain to me or
try to justify why a therapist would tell you to if you are concerned
why they would tell you to off to this stuff. In what universe
would a therapist take that risk? That is not just a joke. Okay?
You shouldn't be joking around with stuff like that. All right?
So there you go. And I've also been told I've also been told
that
he believes
that I'm trying to turn DG against him.
And whatnot. All right. And in order to do that defense, he wants
to turn DG against me. Okay. So, this is basically what we've
been trying to do in the background, like the secret war. Okay.
Now, with that being said, okay, it wouldn't have reached this
point, okay, cuz I I noticed some comments before. It's like
diminished, like they're going like, "Oh my god, three jobs,
you're not significant, okay, you think you're part of the squad,
you're not sign or whatever." Tensions would not escalate to
this point and then deescalate
if it weren't for the fact that he is also taking losses on his
side. Okay.
>> Yeah, that's true. Yeah, that's true. So while on our
side we can count the bodies and whatever, right? Okay, again
I'm not like literally referring to bodies or whatever. I'm saying
like
>> I
I think this is very funny >> in terms of it's it's damaging
both of us. Okay, because it's damaging both of us. This is why
we're deescalating. Okay, so for anybody who says >> does
she think this is gonna deescalate? >> Oh,
you're conceding to Dan Dan saying W. No,
it's because we're we're both like losing out on some stuff.
>> No, you're right. You're right. Food shops,
he's totally calling a ceasefire and everything. There's totally
going to be peace in the Middle East now.
There's uh there's there's totally going to be peace in the Middle
East. >> It's not in our best interest to
>> Oh, this is a total loss for Dan. Yeah. And I think
I think it's really funny that she's bragging about it, that
she's like basically rubbing it in Dan's face. No, I still think
the same thing about your wife and kids and you know you basically
lost you know that you got totally up and good luck war okay
it's not and neither from Dan's perspective is there an interest
okay
he has also said I think from the liaison
that he really wants to deescalate
so deescalation I will provide all right and we will both deescalate
them all right
oh he really Oh, so he came back >> I wish that you know
he has come for to tell this to >> he really wanted to
deescalate guys >> like we would DM each other so then
I don't have to rely on Radiant to do the leazisoning because
honestly I I I don't know like with matters like I I just think
it's really gay, okay, to have like a middle communications person.
Okay. I think that's incredibly gay. In the in the age in the
age of like in the age of communication
in this sphere, in my opinion, there is no excuse to not do direct
contact. Okay? No excuse. Um, especially if you want to be serious
about the escalation. However, I will still respect his wishes.
I will still respect his wishes. Did Radian send screenshots?
No. And I don't need it. Why? because I'm putting it all on Radiant's
name. Okay, so if there is any miscommunication, if there's any
miscommunication
or wait, I'm missing how is nobody showing me these tweets. Hold
on. Tweets popping up in real time. Wait, what was the episcoco
part of
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. What is this? >> At
a certain point, it felt like there was here's what I'll grant,
right?
I think there's a feeling
of defensiveness
for a lot of people,
we'll just say, in the situation. And so I can see someone coming
from that cauldron like looking at my
positions on stuff as part of
a broader trend and of like alliance signaling and stuff like
that. But my mind just doesn't work that way. Never has. And
so I was felt comfortable in every part of that conversation
to answer. >> Is he he's like taking it seriously. Oh,
I totally get how like somebody over there thinks like this means
I'm a lion. Dude, don't take it seriously.
I think it's a little weak, but you know, it is what it is. It
is it is what it is, man. It is what it is. Extorm, you got to
not do that when we're covering other content. Okay, buddy. Love
you. Um, you can be back tomorrow. Thank you. >> Answer
every part of the question. At no point did I want to, in fact,
I wanted to slow down.
Um, and it felt like we were there multiple times during that
conversation where my character was put into question specifically
where, you know, I'm just like, wait, hang on. Let's deal with
what it's fair for me to do this, right? You know, you don't
the fact that I, you know, it's up that
has to So, he went he went live. He talked about this. It's up
that I went live after that stream and then said precisely what
I think he's about to say. How he just wanted to slow down and
analyze why he's being character attacked and then it was just
like ran past.
I do think that's pretty funny, pretty interesting.
Um, and unfortunate for him that I'm going to make the same criticisms
that he's going to make like of totally like like honest to god
criticisms the next morning cuz now I could easily see people
blaming him like watching my bot or like repeating what I'm saying.
But it's just obvious on its face what was happening. >> Phrase
it this way. You understand it. You don't like So it did really
feel like it was um a laundry list of things that at the bottom
there isn't much of a disagreement. I don't think except for
the personalities. It does really feel like u it does really
feel like
the base question is do we think the evidence is overstated
as regards the specific intent that we're talking about? And
you can have a difference of opinion. I think that that's wrong.
But taking one view of that isn't per se bad faith. And nothing
about what I did in in the hunch conversation was at all bad
faith. I promise you. I have these conversations with all different
types of people. And maybe I don't What's he referring to? Oh,
he's referring to like he's referring to the personalities as
I I could translate for you. He's explicitly saying
that Destiny's real criticisms are to do with me and nothing
to do with Pistol. don't communicate well, but the concepts are
consistent and remained consistent and I've always been the same
and I've not changed or backed off of any of those different
positions. Now, that's not to say I've never backed off of a
position before in my life. That's not the case. And I have before
Oh, now now the Dickers tweet doesn't make as much sense to me.
So, I I went to this from like this Dicker tweet, right? Is Destiny
responsible responsible for the harassment he claims JTO and
his community did towards Rose given he is the reason she was
doxed? The only reason they found the rose person was because
I posted the pics in chat to bait them into looking. Um, I think
that's a fair question, man. Oh, see the latest post. Hold on.
He fixed his Yeah. responsible instead of responsibly.
Retweet that. I I feel like I retweet that, dude. Uh, this picture,
it's like I have grown substantially in this picture. I have
like like Chud has minimized away almost entirely. Molina's minimized
away almost entirely. Why do I know this is a picture of Molina?
That's for you to that's for you to wonder. A bad empanada minimized
away almost entirely. It's like me just growing to encompass
all things. It's wild,
dude. This is wild.
Everything's going nuts right now. Everything's going nuts. Everything
is crazy. Okay, give me a second. No, hold on.
Okay, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. What am I doing next? Okay,
I think we are going to go to Candace stuff now, which is too
bad because there's that Pisco thing that we just watched and
I'd love to do more of that, but I should probably get to this
Candace stuff just for the sake of getting to it. We've seen
now that Oh, [__] Wait, was there more? No, I don't
think there's more. We were watching basically Food Chops is
doing a dance of victory. And realistically, I do think you have
to give them the dance of victory on this, right? They won. >> They
against all odds, food shops pulled out the W. Let it never be
said that I'm not fair. Total food shops victory over Dan Saltman
until further notice. Like she seems to have completely won.
I didn't think it was possible. I didn't think Dan could be cow
that way. I thought that was the entire po like the entire point
of his whole thing where he's going to go after you if you go
after people around. But he he just won
It's crazy. So,
how could Dan let this happen? I miss the old Dan. Hey, like
I said from the very beginning,
I I just it feels like no matter what happens here, we get to
win. The worst thing that could happen here is is Dan I still
get to watch Dan have to hang out in a VC with a no